Oh, just say we're live.
We're live. We're a woman.
Look at this picture Brendan shops.
When I ask for my money
tomorrow and fight companion,
Eddie Bravo is so silly. The memes.
First of all, what the fuck are we doing?
Boys were up seven o'clock in the morning.
We're in this fucking studio for
live fights from the Philippines.
If you listening to this podcast,
this is not a regular podcast.
This is what we call a
fight companion podcast,
which means the fights are
on and we will bullshit.
And nine 99 times out of 100 word,
not even talking about the fight,
some of the most hilarious and
entertaining fight companions or fight or,
or podcast,
whether it turn out from this.
But a bottom line is we're all,
we're all exhausted.
It's really early in the morning.
Uh, my man, Eddie Bravo here,
Jujitsu master music producer. Cool
motherfucker. Best friend, Aubrey Marcus,
my brother, a warrior Sharman poet
character. What else? So cool.
Motherfucker Brennan Shab about as
cool as it gets for me. UFC fighter.
Oh current. Maybe we'll see what's
up. Plus the numbers dropped.
Hosted the fighter and the kid podcasts
all around. Cool. Motherfucker again.
And uh, Jamie Vernon who came with
the Krispy Kreme this morning,
like I motherfucker, he brought the
Krispy Kreme donut. Aubrey, by the way,
I want to applaud you on your discipline.
No,
I like haunting me that the
lid is just wafting wafting.
Abra is the only one who hasn't eaten.
Did you have any Krispy Kreme? Yeah. Yeah,
we all ate it. Fuck it. I, I'm
a little disappointed Opry.
Cause now I've now I feel bad.
And you're all shredded in the
cage and he ate a donut. Oh yeah.
But he doesn't give up.
We are here watching highlights of Costa
Philippoussis smashing people and uh,
he's going to take on Kkr Mu Saucy
and look at Port Gianna Anak.
Brian Stann antics do hair.
How about Stan? He's like,
I could be home right now. They're
both like, he's in the Philippines.
He's like fucking Brad Pitt right now.
You're talking about and he's
having a great time. Well,
the Philippines can imagine if you could
catch it right after Manny Pacquiao one.
Ooh, I catch that wave.
Goddamn, they'd be so happy.
You see those videos was photos of all
the people watching? No, there's no crime.
When he fights, it's the one day where
there's no crime in the Philippines.
The entire nation stops to
watch him fight. I believe
it. True Story. I believe it,
man.
I wonder how they're going to
fuck that dude. Watch your watch your
p's and q's. That's Manny Pacquiao, bro.
Well, you know that's just, I dunno.
It's like thousands of islands. I think
there's thousands. Not a thousand.
I think there's thousands of islands.
I didn't know that.
I wish I had the energy to Google
it. God, I want my boy mark me. It
comes to when computer right here.
It would be nice. You want his last,
his last fight in the Philippines.
Not that I don't like Luke.
I looked Lou Barnett. Yeah. I
like Luke a lot. Mark is my,
he's just such a good boy. We need
them to win. He's such a good dude.
Tried to bet on that Eddie or why you went
Luke, what's going on? No, no, no, no, no,
no. Is My boy. No, but
people used to think I was
Filipino growing up, so fuck
that. Yeah, but you're not.
You're definitely not though.
People think I'm Mexican.
I don't root for cane every time.
But you're born Aaron Hernandez.
He gets convicted yesterday. Uh,
it looks like now. Right? He's a,
he's got some other side of
you just kills bitches though.
He's the opposite of you. Like
you're such a sweet guy. I know.
He is a very mean person. Yeah.
It can't be killing people, man.
It was 7,107 islands in the Philippines.
Islands must be cheap.
You could probably buy it to grant.
Right?
Sometimes they only stick around for a
couple of months and then go on to waters.
Why?
They're cheap.
They're like the realtors at the 30%
line right now that will be underwater
within five years and just look
at the islands available. Oh,
well here we got about
6,000 I have no idea.
That's like super gangster money if you
could buy an island. Yeah, I knew that.
I knew it was over a thousand.
I thought it was thousands.
I didn't think it was 7,000 all right.
Aaron Hernandez,
what do you think you
got how many years ago?
I know the Boston bomber didn't get
the death penalty. Makes Sense, right?
The fuck are we doing?
Yeah, there's a screen.
Who got life? Whoa. Yeah.
He gets two more. Right?
Cause he's convicted of the one
murder of Odin Lloyd Wright life.
Could they escalate to death? Whoa. Maybe
can't kill people. Yeah, that's
not cool. Oh Shit. Oh Shit.
Anyone who knows him said they can't
believe he made it this long without
getting cut. I guess he's just a
bad dude. I don't really know that.
I didn't look into that story.
Yeah, that's kind of everywhere.
And his ball players, football,
football player, super scary guy.
Just a gangster, super talented guy. Crazy
talent position. Does he play tied in?
Won a national championship and
a super ball with the Patriots.
Take a look at you on,
apparently it's just fall.
My football man. Very Meta. It's why
he played football. But I shit Kevin,
no football. Okay. Nando's was a big deal.
And everyone compared, the two of us was,
it just, was he just crazy like
what was his deal? He grew up super,
super hoodie and in the gang.
So this is the thing man.
So he got all that money and the one
teeny should have been drafted to was the
new England patriots cause he was from
Connecticut. So he didn't escape the game.
That's your ass skids.
Yeah.
I used to work in new haven and new, hey,
it's not Mexicans. This Puerto Rican,
Puerto Rican and
black dude. They were saying if he got
drafted by any other team, I'm mean,
I'm sure he still would've killed itches,
but it was just way worse.
Cause he's had all his homies there
and then you have $40 million.
You don't get a guy like
that. $40 million. What'd
you think was gonna Happen?
And he had 40 million bucks,
40 million.
How much money they make
playing football yet load,
especially a guy of his caliber.
What do you think about deflate gate?
I think it's bullshit.
I think it's such bullshit.
I think Tom Brady would
beat them no matter what.
Make all the balls deflate everyone's
balls. Tell me how it goes.
You didn't walk away. It's bullshit is
because everybody had the same Paul. Yeah.
The other team had that
ball to see they still won.
Even if the ball was like
slightly deflated. No, they
did it. They didn't. Yeah,
it's not true. I'm going to help you out.
Yeah. Well so, so who gave me the help?
Give me that. So each team has their
own balls, right? The ball boy,
the quarterback before they
came a field the ball. So they,
there's an Indianapolis colts ball and
then there's a new of the Patriots Ball.
Well then what's the problem?
Well, there's say Tom's
was deflated so it made it,
it's fucking stupid. Exactly.
Deflate. Let me know how it goes.
Any but all the NFL is like, it
doesn't fucking matter. It's so stupid.
But all the NFL things, it doesn't
matter. The players get all the papers.
He got Smith for games. How
many games you, ray rice gets.
It's better for beating the
shit out of his girlfriend to
follow NFL.
What the fuck are we doing?
You got it.
You fucking dummies.
You got to at least suspend that
guy for as many times together.
Ray Rice in his girl. Yeah. Yeah. They're
married. Left. She didn't press charges.
Yeah. Incredible. Have you
seen that video? I have.
He hit her with a left hook like
Mark Hunt. You can't do that, man.
It's like Donald's number. How raise
your product use throw that shovel hook.
He's still like, dude,
remember that? Oh yeah.
It was more like Tommy Morrison's left
Hook. Tommy Morrison's left. Took,
he would leap panel to power. I
just leaped in. May Worsen. No,
raise your Ruddock would catch pitches
moving away. Yeah, that's what he did.
Raise your resume. Brodick Tyson. He gave
me trouble. Okay. Did raise it right?
That was after prison? No, that was pre
prison. It was Tyson. Are you sure? Oh,
I'm 100% sure. Okay. Yeah,
I'm pretty sure. Yeah. He, um,
he raised her rug versus Tommy
who was actually a good fight.
Tommy Marson stopped him.
It was kind of a bullshit stoppage.
But he did rock him with a left hook,
cracked him with a left hook and hurt him.
Then just threw a bunch of punches
at his arms. That's one fine. It was,
I saw it cause I actually was a Tommy
Morris and Fiat fanny and I felt sorry for
white people.
You know what I mean?
Mexicans and blacks just killing everybody
in boxing. So I like a one white guy.
I'm not white, but I would pull for the
white guy cause I thought, see shit man.
I appreciate it. Yeah. Tommy
Morris. I was like, oh, come on.
Like a white running back.
Yeah,
it was watching him in Tuesday night
fights from that shit. He thought a man,
he was fighting, um, uh, Michael bed.
He was supposed to just
go right through Michael.
Ben and Michael Beck just lit him.
It was one of the most brutal knockouts
in boxing history. He was shredded man.
Tell me more. So it was
Shradda his projects. He's
too nervous. He died, right?
Well and then, yeah, he died. Yeah, he,
he's dead. How many Morrison died? Yeah.
I just found this that age. I know he
had aids, but I didn't know he died.
Most people don't, not the healthy
you let your magic Johnson,
but he didn't have aids. He was
just HIV positive. He never,
he never even came close to having names.
They gave him the best way at the superior
periods. Yeah. Made them good. Um,
but Marson before he died had peck
implants. It was really crazy.
And it was meth out of his fucking
mind. He was on meth. Yeah. Well his,
you got to see what he looked like. Some
people call that live in brother. Yeah.
That's what I say. His body was all
fucking weird man. About methods.
There's people that have done,
met their whole fucking life
and they're still alive.
How do you go 10 years of doing
math and how does your body adapt?
How do stuff teeth start? Terry Hill,
the referee is standing in the middle of
the octagon. You gotta set of tits off.
Who is the [inaudible] the referee that
let Mark Hunt almost get his brains
beaten in by steep bamio
chick. He was British. Right.
That should be fine. Okay, so these
two gentlemen are going at it.
One of them is a diva in the
red and McCosh Marrakesh,
Villi. So you don't have my money? Is
that what you're saying? I got your money.
You got your money, right. Oh, this,
let's just talk about that check.
Well, how would you like
it? I'm kind of like a bank.
They made a bet during the last
UFC fight companion that uhm,
Brennan shops. Boy Pat Cummins was going
to beat Osp, otherwise known as, oh,
Vince St Pru over at Saint Prue shut dim
lights out. Yeah, he did a first round.
He's got cash for you.
He's got $1,000 cash.
They made 1,900 Rfu one by twister.
There's like $10,000 Oh no,
we didn't shake on that.
We did.
We were all the files,
all the nothing. Do you want to
go double or nothing? I got Edgar.
You got favor? No, I got,
I got Frankie. Doug. Hmm.
I won't Frankie. Wow, this is interesting.
Now you guys don't want to take favor.
I think favorite one 35 is the
man or one 45 is a motherfucker.
Motherfucker take him.
Well, no. Hey listen.
Faber's a bad motherfucker. No doubt
about it. But Frankie Edgar, man,
it's hard to bet against him at 45.
That's a hard pick.
Another solid pick another fight.
I really don't know.
What about Musashi Musashi?
You want full of poop now I got my sauce.
What about Munoz? I got Munoz. Who Do you
got? How about limb and magnate magnate?
I don't know. That's an interesting, your
boy bag is my boy. Who's he fighting?
That's a tough fight. He's fighting. H how
did he say his name? [inaudible]. Garlin.
Um, hold on a second. Let me pull
it up. You know what? You know what?
I'll take favor Williams. Bad mother
double or nothing. Whoa. Take favor.
You don't want,
I think favor is going to,
I'm envisioning it and had the weeds
hit me. He's going to win this fight.
I got a favor. I just saw
it. Good. I just saw it.
I don't know
double or nothing.
Don't fuck around. So, so, so you get 1800
1800 yeah,
this is $900 1800 all right,
cool. Come on. Favorite? God dammit
like Kramer will.
His body is going to look incredible.
I could see a winning.
I'm really nervous now.
That's a close fight. I
really regret that dad. No, he
doesn't regret it. He's happy.
He just fucking with me.
I'm super nervous.
Favorite 45 is a total wildcard.
We haven't seen him in 45 and a long time.
At 35 I would have taken
favor right away real quick.
And he's never lost a
non title fight favors.
Never last one on title
one thing at one 45 yeah.
And you know Frankie fought at 55
Frankie small though man, but he's still,
he could handle dudes to 55 right,
but don't you think that favor
will like for his age, like he's,
I think he just turned 37 37 36
yeah, he's, he just had a birthday.
He's like,
as you get older it's probably harder
and harder to fight really well after he
cut weight. Yeah, right. You're
getting a lot of weight. I'm gonna be,
maybe we'll see a better. I think he, he
kept, he kept getting better, you know,
I mean,
you can't go back to the time he fought
for the title at 45 against Aldo because
I really feel like back then that's
a different favor than you see now.
I think cravers better. I
think he's better now. Yeah.
And remember nobody had the ground
and pound favor head back in the day.
He doesn't do it as a back
in the days. Yeah. He doesn't
do it anymore, but he can.
I just think his game expanded so much.
Right in the beginning, Faber's game was,
I'm going to take you down.
I'm not even gonna try to pass your guard.
I'm going to stay in your guard and I'm
going to clench down on you and stack
you and smash you and then do like a
back extension thing. Explosion Hub.
Bring the bottom dude up and then he
comes down and hits you with an elbow as
you hit the ground. He just come up
with his elbows. Nobody does that.
She can't sleep on that. Getting
either. Dammit guys figure has,
how's he going to be cranky
though? Skills. He's not
going to wrestle. Frankly.
You have to choke him.
Why do you think more people didn't do
ground and pound like him? Even today?
They don't do it like that.
Is it the guys who like you could do that.
He picks the ground. Remember
that Shit, whatever that Cro,
cop Daga side of the guard.
But to this day sometimes I wake up
in the middle of the night and go, oh,
those are the best. Yeah, definitely.
If those weren't the best elbows in
the guard and MMA, their top three,
top three best elbows in the
Gar Jones and Jones is the best.
Brandon Vera. Yeah, but in Broomfield,
I mean that was really good fight.
But think how long John is to truth
those elbows. That's the difference.
It's true.
But the crow,
there's something really special about
cro cop doing it because first of all it
came out of him being on top.
So,
and then he'll hit him with elbows and
all he was complaining about before the
fight was grappling and elbows are
ruining MMA. And that's his spot.
Grappling and elbows one him that fight.
It was so crazy.
He really fucking with a lot of
fights there. Punching Shit for Roche,
bringing wrestler, start working his
takedowns. That's where it needs to be.
He needs to take, I just put
in the guard. You know what?
Standing. He's gun shy. Now let's not
get out of control here. Hey listen,
he's gun shy standing. He is
and he's worried about his
Chan. He's getting older.
Let's not sugarcoat it.
Yes, so I believe this.
I believe he should be in the garden.
Fucking people up based on
that performance. That might
be as new spot standing.
It seems spot. He's not.
He's telling bitches down.
Well they do that. He's a
strong, he's the strongest dude.
You ever feel strong as fuck, but he
wasn't taking me down. Come on man.
It's crazy. Well, maybe you
could learn how to take people
down. Oh yeah, for sure.
Every time I'm fucking 40 he's
going to switch into a grappler.
Isn't it weird that Weidman is
not the main event next week?
It seems weird to me.
Sue Weidemann Belfort.
That feels like the main event for me.
Not there's anything wrong with
Carmie a Johnson, but it's like,
you know we, we both, we all know,
we know that Jon Jones is the champ.
They took John Joe's title away for
non fighting activity type shit.
What did think about that and we talked
about John John's. No, we have it.
Have you talked about it? I've talked
about it. What's y'all got strip him.
Kind of strip him. Yeah, you
have to have two. But however,
even if he's not training and he's sitting
in jail, where the fuck you he's at,
he's still the best fighter on the planet.
There's no,
there's no legit light heavyweight
champion. Whoever wins that.
It's not the real champion.
Right.
The only one who had a chance of proven
that is rumble because of rumble beats
core me a, we still don't know if he
would have been able to beat jai agree.
[inaudible] beats rumble then
warn them like weird Tim. What?
We got this guy who's clearly, he's
a champ, but he's not the champ.
Then Johnson come fresh out of prison.
Just a gut ready to destroy somebody.
Yeah.
He's going to be a heavyweight and
come out of prison. Yeah, he might did.
He's going to roar. No one's going
to fuck with John's not looking.
Good man. Guys are probably going to test
them. Usually people just for their bat.
The only way it'll work out,
the only way it'll work out apparently
is if he some sort of a settlement with
the woman I, they get together and he
says, look, here's 1 million bucks.
What's let the shit go away?
Signs of paperwork,
which is very possible
and the smart thing to do,
if you don't want to go to
jail, that's priceless. Right?
Like you should give her 2 million.
That was kind only be
the civil charges though.
The criminal charges come
from the police, right. Felony
home. Yes. Yes, yes. But, um,
I think it's lessened in
some sort of a strange way.
If the woman won't press charges. It's
two felonies though, right? That is true.
Right. He ran from the scene of the
crime, like, yeah, he's probably,
he probably can't escape your left his
car and just started running. No, no, no.
Came back. This is where he's fucked
because if you leave the scene,
you can say whatever head trauma is
fucked up. I was out of it, so I ran.
But if you're smart enough to come back
and get your cash and then run off,
now you're fucked. That's not gonna work
because you were smart enough to go, oh,
hold up, my cash is there. Let me
go back and grab it. Who knows what?
And then he got as well, you know,
he say he got his cash like you just,
you've seen a fucking dude in a Hoodie,
grabbed some shit with his hand.
It looks like cash.
That could have been a bunch of other
things involved in that hand, you know?
I mean, who knows what the
fuck he grabbed. It's just
sad. It's Super Sad, man.
He ran most sad for the woman obviously
is, I think it was probably high.
I think he was high and he,
you got to remember he got in trouble.
He got in trouble before.
And from what I've heard
is if you leave the scene,
you're less likely to get in
trouble. Does that make sense? Yes.
I heard a cop say if you get in an
accident and you are high and you run,
that's the best case scenario.
What kind of a cop you talking to him?
That is true. That is shady,
shady time. Just fucking sleep.
Especially if you're talking about,
especially if you're high,
if you're high or on substance and you
run the charges or less depending on what
city or cause a Dui, that's gonna fuck
you up. Way Worse than fleeing the scene.
Now, this isn't like that
advice. If anybody's listening
here, this is terrible.
This is Maddie's. Maybe. Maybe that's
John Jones. Both for your own errors.
Don't run away.
Well,
I think John had already had that one
DUI and if he was in fact fucked up,
he was probably in full panic mode.
I mean he just got the Reebok deal.
He was making really good money. He's
doing all these commercials for Reebok.
Louise Hay at Instagram
pictures constantly all the
time and he knew that was
going away. Everything was going away.
Most likely the title's going away.
Public perception can be terrible.
The whole thing was a disaster.
I think he just, he just needs
to embrace this. It's awful.
I can't fuck you guys chose me to peruse.
Yeah. That's what he needs
to do. That's what's up.
He needs to convince the judge
to some jail. Osca I wasco.
We'll show him all a 30 times already.
Where are we going to say?
Do I need to do what? I think he embraces
the and role. No, he can't. Yeah,
like the WWE PCC,
he's got to realize that he's like,
he's operating on momentum and meaning
that like I think with John John's is
doing right now, I think life is
like almost out of control forum.
I think the overwhelming,
like all the pressure now,
the craziness involved in being
the youngest ever UFC champion,
the light heavyweight champion,
the craziest fucking fights and knowing
that some of his fights sets really
shitty camps,
that's what makes them great Harney in.
So you want to cage that line and be like
loose doesn't necessarily mean that it
doesn't make him great. Great.
No, he is great and there's that.
It doesn't make him great. What makes
them great as his training. It's just,
he's so good that he can get by
with all the trainings already done.
Being half out of shape and beat a
guy like Alexander Gustafson. True.
But I think if you take a guy like
that and you say, all right man,
you gotta quit being you and you got
to live in this house, nine to five,
go to training, come back. You
can't party. Can't do any of that.
He's not going to be as good or as
creative that some guy you say that the
restraints on.
Yeah,
but you only say that like we don't
know because we never seen him do it.
It was supposed to be doing it for this
fight. Obviously he wasn't killing,
you know, there's a lot.
It was a balance man. Yeah.
There's a lot of famous stars that
are known coke heads for sure.
People just, and they kept it from
people. Well, how about Tyson?
Tyson in his prime would be coked
up and fights Lawrence Taylor.
That's not clear because when he doesn't
really say that he was high during the
fight. I heard, I heard. I thought
he did. He said he was high.
He was doing coke during that time,
but he's not specifically saying
that he was doing it in the fight.
Lawrence Taylor came out,
admitted he played high all the time.
What my cane and he's one of the
best players ever, ever. Or its tail.
Is it a rumor that fact that Joe
Montana was had problems with coke?
I'm not sure. How dare you bring
Joe? All types on tannins missing.
Hi Tyson and Mr being high on drugs
during major fights and using a fake penis
to avoid detection.
Well,
pretty clear that marijuana,
cocaine is beaten bitches up.
Joe's made out fuck Jones.
John Jones Jones may not
have had a problem with coke.
He might've just been partying one night.
Like if you're doing it that close to
a fight, you got a problem, you think,
you know? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Maybe.
I think what I think for him,
he's just got to reconcile who he truly
is. Like I think he tried to play this,
I'm nice guy.
And then that Kinda got busted with DC
and then he was kind of left with this
perception gap of what he was trying to
portray and what he actually knew that
he was inside.
And I think he's just got to reconcile
that and just be truly what he is.
If he's a fine,
just be a fucking savage what I'm saying,
just be be truly who you are.
And then
chocolate though was a
different kind of dude.
You know chocolate though was wild party
dude, but he wasn't like what Jon Jones,
his situation is first of all,
driving drunk.
There's a big different like chocolate
party I guaranteed probably get limos or
something like that.
Like he never got busted drunk driving
and the driving parts of big one,
chocolate.
Dell embraced his celebrity
more than any fighter I knew.
He just, he had, he loved it.
He had a great time.
He was man,
he was on his after parties.
I mean he's just on fire.
He's just like his after [inaudible] just
talking about how he fuck these dudes
up and everyone's like, fuck, this
is jug and everyone's taking shots.
He's taking shots. It's like he could just
like at the club called raw, like it's,
the game's changed don.
He was so fucking God damn nice.
And I'm not just saying that cause I have
a, he's a friend of mine. He's a bit,
yeah, he's so cool. He's one of the
coolest guys ever. He's a great guy.
We haven't talked about this
fight once the game's changed.
That's all I'm saying.
Two minutes ago I say John Jones
should just be the Choco Dolo the two
thousands.
I just don't you think you can make the
comparison chocolate [inaudible] never
thought it was a bad guy
and he liked to party.
But like people think of John as a bad
guy. Chuck was at fake either like chuck.
Chuck didn't put on this
reconciliation confused.
He was just a caveman with a Mohawk.
It's just a weird thing to see a
guy is young and talented as John.
Repeat the same mistakes that you've seen
all these other young talented guys do.
It's heartbreaking, man. It is. Jay.
This is probably a really good fight.
I'm not mad at the trunks
old school. You know, we,
we literally, I have no idea who won
this fight. We barely paying attention.
I could not tell you this is like
watching the fights in the stands though.
If you watch the fights in the stands,
like sometimes like before
I would work for the UFC,
we were watch fights in the
stands and someone would go, what?
He won really when we're sure
that this isn't whole shit.
Every time I looked up he was kicking ass.
Dude.
How about those first few IFCs Zufolo
took over and we were all dreaming of that
day.
Well the UFC would be an ed
to MGM or Mandalay like fog.
One of these days did one of these
days and it fucking happened.
We were right there. Ringside. We had
the best seats in the fucking ass.
What was it? Merlin's with Montay versus
chocolate. Dell error. Yeah. Miller.
Bustamante no, no, no.
It's been a real boost.
Bustamante versus goddammit.
The fuck is his name?
Dave Manet.
No,
my computer's going off shit. How the fuck
did he fight? Oh, Matt Lindland wasn't,
that was Matt was it,
was it?
I know he was there for saccharine
and Matt Hughes were there for soccer.
I'm mad. He was, remember that fight and
they'd cut, they'd come over. Uh, uh,
Ryan Bennett would come over.
He was the roving reporter guy and Joe.
So what do you think of the UFC reverted
and the gel would just be like watching,
he just rattle off like the coolest line
to go. UFC is kind of like baseball,
blah blah blah blah blah blah,
blah.
This cool ass quote that he would just
have ready to go and then they would use
that and the promos for the next
UFC and then they just asked like,
shit,
when you commentate.
Then once he started commenting,
I'm like sitting there by myself,
Mike,
fuck
this is,
yeah,
they talked me in to work and cause it
to get those kinds of seeds to is the
maximum.
We're not going to give you four of those
motherfuckers are going to get killed
or you're going to get one and you're
going to be happy with it. Right.
This guys can pound it on it. Can I get
one from my girlfriend? Yeah, I know, man.
That's fucking great. That
was back in the day, dude.
We were there before I
even worked for the EOC,
so that was like 2001 and maybe two.
And there's a video that's on youtube
still wear. Uh, Brian Cowen when at once.
And we were having,
we were pregaming in the hotel room at
the MGM and it was one of those first
five UFC. He's in Vegas.
We were like in Vegas,
in a hotel room with Callan blips.
Callen was there this video,
this video somewhere. Where is that video?
What is it called? Brazilian. Brazilian.
This slime Cowen doing his character,
you know that character he does, they're
the, the male raping them. The other men,
you know, sometimes it doesn't
as a Brazilian, rarely.
Sometimes it's Brazilian.
Yeah, he does it. And it was one of
the funniest things of all time, a man.
And what we were crying,
laughing me a crying.
We got kicked out of the hotel because
there's like, there was so porn star,
Bj Bjj, gay porn star,
a manager at Google that
pop up. There it is. There it is.
This is one of the funniest goddamn
things. Brian Count if ever done.
You know what's fucked up about it? The
way they filmed it, it was an Easter egg.
It was back when people put
Easter eggs in their DVD.
So the video you get is this tiny little
fucking video. Yeah. Like that. Yeah.
Like look at, look at the kick this back
and he was the kid. Oh, where's the case?
His back when he was the kid. He doesn't
age. Can you start it over real quick?
This is a, this is actually
his turn. Hold on. Hold on.
This is is a Henzel Gracie impression.
By the way, bring it to the beginning.
Young Jamie part. Hanzo part. Hinata the,
it's a combination of, yeah. You know,
you guys just take a guy sometimes
do my man.
I may
talk to him like dad deep.
[inaudible] my hand now.
Oh look,
nothing.
Just
licking his fingers. Hold him
down with that. I knew. Was that
okay?
Can you explain me?
That's my persona.
The SEC size guys don't understand for
me. Mike Coke, what I'm going to do now.
Did that go on
to
porn or something like that?
Nothing
gets my boils. Nah Man. Get my book
and this is probably 2014 years ago.
You guys are, how can we will call? We
got kicked out of that hotel room, dude.
We left that hotel room in the security
guard was coming down the hallway.
He goes, well you guys are making all
that noise. And we were like, Nah,
we don't know what you're talking about
man. I know what you're talking about.
It sounds like Hensdale right?
Oh my God, he's so funny man.
And that was 2001 or two somewhere else,
but I don't,
I wasn't even working for the
UFC back then. You're just chill.
You guys are just chilling. And
we were just having fun. Vegas.
We just went to see some fights. Yeah. And
then he, then he always have rattle off.
That's cool ass quote. And
then Dana, just stop man.
What you want to commentate a whole show.
And then Joe goes,
do they want me to commentate? Commentary
is fun, but this might be the shit
fight companions that he's not
responsible for to be tension.
I don't fight fight. I'm sure you won,
sir. You look like you're well powerful.
Misha Tate in the house.
Hey Yo, what's up girl?
So pretty quiet. Whole,
whole degree. Be Shy. Yeah.
All of those. All, all of us. Just
how heavy breathing is the mic?
Yes. Smile at the camera. Pretty
much. He saw, swore off all of us.
We're lucky we're in
the scanning her face.
Tigall take a little bit. Did she?
She did some with those, right?
Something happened there. Something Great.
No one cares about that shit. People.
Good tip. Get a tip jar.
What I'm saying is though,
it's weird to do that
while you're fighting white
bumps. You out what? Strong.
Stand by me. Wrong stance. Aubrey.
I don't love for you to be friends.
That's a fucking IOWASCA.
Did you do like a bunch of weird drawing?
What do you do with them? I mean,
I dunno. Whatever you do you do with
them. Well, I'm not like nothing.
I'm not a big like a boob guy.
Oh, I am asked legs. Why pick?
You could have
it all.
It's all about the acid
lake is a very important,
why pick if you're getting hot enough
girls, there's no reason to panic.
They have pretty faces. Nice
titties. Perfect as small ways.
I mean the tin is just like the
rest of the body. It's like a arm.
We can't talk about that on the show.
What do you mean?
It's like the rest of the body.
There's,
it's not really a sex organ in that
maybe we can't talk to you anymore. Yeah,
you'd be surprised. Nonsense.
Crazy. What about when,
when you girls on top of, and she's
forced feeding those while riding it.
He told me those are awesome.
They're wonderful. Hi,
I'm Marie.
I'm a big fan.
Fuck is going on over there early.
So I'm gonna give you a Holbeck
earliest fun so you get a whole dance.
I think
mammaries look better in clothes.
Like when they're kind of
hanging out there like nice.
They're fake and they're barely hanging
out. You know what I mean? That's like,
you know, you can't, you can't
deny that. You're just like, damn,
what the duties are. Just anxious to see
the nipple and you could just, you know,
they're real different now. The new
fake ones, they feel like real tip man.
It's not like a bag of water like the
olden days now it's like a silicon,
like gummy bears. Yeah, it's the,
it's very similar to the texture
of an actual breast cancer from,
it's just a little more firm.
It's a totally different animal now.
I prefer it to do you remember those
two porns where the girls be like,
guy would be banging the girl and they
would have these weird strike the ripples
underneath their tits. He
goes, I'm watching madness.
I'm living at madness. Something
about it. It was crazy.
I worked in a strip club industry for
10 years. I saw plenty of that. Yeah.
But I mean, you know it in
porn, but it was real bright.
So the thing about porn is that like,
you know, they're fucking close up an HD.
When HD came along to porn,
the whole fucking game got weird because
then you could see those nipple scars
where they just take a fucking apple core
to the netball and just stuff, a bag.
Just ditch that fucker back up.
Like it was a totally different
thing that you could see everything.
Do they still cut the nipples?
They can go through the warpit or nipples
they go through the armpit or below
the breast to is very popular now.
You'd never,
I don't think going through
the nipples a good idea.
It doesn't seem like a good idea.
It seems like your nipples are going to
look all frankensteinish powerful Uriah
Faber, ready to rock and Commodity
Ryan looking thing thick at life.
I'd be like my boy, he like Dick
Surgery going through the balls.
You don't want to risk very similar
Felipe.
No. In the house. You Chill
Nam. He's a handsome guy.
Maybe it will be there. He was like,
when he was on the ultimate fighter, uh,
Dana White thought that that dude was
going to be like the next Anderson.
He called him the next Anderson Silva.
Well,
he was knocking people fucking dead when
he was on the ultimate fighter. Yeah.
You don't call him Anderson
Silva. I know. Well there's also,
the problem was you have to really be
considering what it's hot in here. Huh?
Ac could put a little
ac on young Jamie. I'm not mad
at that. Terry is right there.
There he is right there.
That's him on the ultimate fighter.
He was fucking people up in the ultimate
fighter. It's an ultimate fighter. Yeah.
That's the thing. Like you got to think
of the level of quality of opposition.
These racing me, he looked like a killer
against good guys. Yeah, but that,
that's not real.
That's not the right.
That's why when they made it out of
the UFC to talk to guys and I'm like,
this is just a tryout to get on the
roster. You're not fighting killing shit.
Everyone's like you man.
And then you get in the UFC and you're
fighting legit professional UFC fighters.
Big different animal man.
I went from demicco Rogers who had three
fights that Gabriel Gonzaga within like
whatever, a year, year and
a half. Yeah. A difference.
Isn't that a weird thing that they did?
That is a crazy like fast track to
like elite competition almost too much.
So, right. For some guys. Yeah, for sure.
Like there's a few that could like swim.
They could make that swim. I think
if you had that Calvin. Yeah.
If you have a serious
like wrestling background,
it really helps you look at a guy
like Cain, Josh Koscheck. Yeah,
Calvin gas, Tulum, coven.
Gasoline is in the mix right now
at one seven he's one of the, well,
if he makes one 70 fights, Nate Marquardt
names who's I bet. Very interesting.
Very interesting fight.
Very interesting fight and
really interesting only
because you got to factor in
how much mileage Nate has on him.
I wish Nate,
Nate's a very close friend and I'm going
to bring him in here to have the Joe
Rogan talk.
I can't have it with him because then
he'll have the Jesus talk with me and
we'll be at a standstill. I know it's
going to be good podcast, you know?
I don't know him like I know you.
I love you. I know brother. I know.
I'm just saying with, with Nate, I,
I wish someone could get through.
I want them to,
when I started,
Nate was the baddest motherfucker ever.
He fucked up everybody and anybody,
you name them,
they would bring like GSP would
fly Nate to Montreal, Rashad Evans,
all these guys.
Nate was the baddest motherfucker I knew.
So now when I watch him fight him like,
oh my God,
he's a shell and I'm going to take some
heat for saying that from my friends.
But he is. It's true, man.
It's horrible to watch. You
could only run so many miles.
She can only get hit so many times. Your
body can only take so many body slams,
chokes, armbars head kicks. All those
things add up and you get to a point,
unless you've read retort Belfort.
How the fuck is this?
We're just looking at him right now.
I think there are different supplements.
Well, I don't know you do. You realize
he's tested Clinton, Bro, dare you.
Oh,
you gotta realize too,
Nate's been fighting hold hold since
he was 17 why beat door since he was 19
yeah.
He just two to a point.
Both at the same nutritional type. No,
I don't think so. No. I don't know.
Even though Nate has been busted
but different. Nate got busted.
His levels were so high when they
pulled him off of that fight.
They six story fight.
Yeah. It's like this guy.
Good like dye in there like we can't,
you can't let it go fight
with those levels coming.
This is coming right from the head of
the Athletic Commission to
my fucking heroes. I was on
the same card. He was like,
we can't fight like that. You can't
like, they have levels that you're,
you're supposed to be when
they like that was by the way,
when he was having legal TRT, his
levels were, it wasn't a matter,
but it was fucking wild.
Cat levels still got the same Shit Tore,
Huh? Vitorin Brazil. They're like,
good lord man. He tested when they,
when he came to Vegas,
they tested him.
And this is one of the reasons why they
pulled the whole Party thing in the
first place.
They made it publicly aware.
So I'm not saying anything that people
don't know. 1,475 was his level.
The healthy man is like 500 like
a healthy young man in his prime.
800 to 1500 some stud,
some fucking Herschel Walker Stud.
Now this guy,
1,475 that's like you're in some alien
territory and kicking bitches in the face.
He knocked out. Yeah, there's still
subway did a Luke Rockhold huh?
We'll Keck. Fuck are we doing
velop kicks when there's a,
there's a lot of guys out there
that just stuck with boxing.
They never 10 remove his brother.
That's Henry Hoover. It's true.
That's a big part of that.
Henri Hooft is a bad motherfucker.
Point is such a good guy.
There's,
there's all these guys out there
that are just, boxing is doing.
You can do it to anybody.
Could do. You're totally right.
And you know the other thing happened.
He broke his hands so many times.
He kind of had to develop kicks.
Vito broke his hands.
He told me he had seven operations on
his hands. She says, yeah, set. And when?
When I met him in Brazil one of times I
met him in Brazil like maybe like three
years ago or so.
He had a pen in his hand while we were
eating Goldberg and I restaurant and
eating and they have,
you know,
they have these pins and then they
pull them out when they're done.
Like my daughter had to get one
when she broke her arm, the skin.
So he's hanging out with us and he'd
show I got to get these pulled out right
here, you know, he was like
totally cool about it. I'm like,
how many times you break your head.
Did they ever put,
seem to never leave the metal in?
I know they do that with
skiers and they do it some,
some really significant compound injuries,
like a normal thing and he's
just got shit on my friend.
Vodi has a whole like metal hand,
my whole stubs battle.
If you see this big scar,
my whole sub,
here's metal and I had those
same pins sticking out.
Your whole thumb is metaware right
here. So that's all metal? Yup.
Where that biggest scars? That's it get
cold as fuck. When it's that does an aix,
does it vibrate? I don't, I
don't think. What do you try and
fake titties?
So Felipe Novera he hasn't fought in the
UFC in a long time, right? My correct.
Yeah, you're correct. This is first
flight back. Is it? Pretty sure,
but he fought and some other
organizations I know in the UFC cut him.
He did still have some fights. I didn't
hear much about them though. Yeah,
he's been traded at I those and just
kind of doing work. Well wait a minute,
when fresh hair of some thing
where he would faint, didn't have,
he had like a medical conditions.
Dizzy goats? No, no, no.
Something was wrong with them. Like
they couldn't figure out what was wrong.
Is that
him? I'm pretty sure. I'm
pretty sure there was something,
something where they were saying he
might not ever be able to fight again,
but I guess they cured it up.
Whatever it was.
The Filipino Anderson Silva moving around.
Ooh.
[inaudible] still got good hands.
Phillipe Novera was when he was good.
He was very good.
He was a nurse from that. Yeah.
In like Brooklyn or some shit.
Gaylord cozy for the take
down. Hands up grace, Jujitsu
and lamb tries to hit that switch.
Let's see what kind of ground game.
No bear house. He's a Hanzo Guy,
right? Yeah. Cause he a black belt.
I would say yes because what was he,
he was like a purple result on the
ultimate fighter. That was a while ago.
He's still tapped his training.
Yeah.
This is interesting. It's interesting
to see a guy fight. He's Filipino.
Right?
Which is probably one of the reasons
why they brought him in here fighting in
the Philippines. Right. Huge
reset, right? Yeah. Oh yeah.
I mean you would want to like the
one the UFC goes back to Dublin.
I imagine they're going to get every
fucking Irish fighter they could possibly
imagine. And put them on
the card. Makes Sense. Yeah.
Cause they do the same thing.
Mexico into Mexico, right? Yeah.
That's going to be fun,
man.
Mexico cane versus a Purdue for doing it.
That you really do. Eddie Bravo.
There's your bet are there.
If you want any interaction, you
want some more. Eddie man. Oh,
Aubrey just said he's in. Then
you're, I got your hockey bag.
I got Verbeek silver doom over cane.
Whoa.
Keynes had her fresh young 10 years off.
He's had a lot of time.
A lot of times he's injured every other
week. Yeah. But if it was anybody else,
I would, I would agree with you.
But Cain is superhuman. I agree.
But for or skin pad or, yes,
it's definitely getting better,
but I go ahead and take him down
cane. Yeah, that's true. That right.
And enjoy trying to ground and
pound them. I agree. You know,
according to Ryan Parsons, he said
when he was training with the King Mo,
he said they would take volume
down and nothing they did worked.
He's like none of the ground and
pound worked on them and she goes,
it's the most ridiculous thing
you've ever seen your life.
It's like the fade or fight.
Once he starts getting his feet on your
hips and manipulating you around like
you, you, you've never seen a guard like
that. And he's huge. Yeah. Huge, huge,
real heavy. You don't realize how tall
fucking redeem his man. He's a big boy.
Remember when he kept up and then kicked
fucking Travis Browne the body? Yeah.
Bed chipped up from his back and then
Roy Travis,
I think,
uh,
I think Cain Velasquez we'll
take down for dome at will. Yeah,
he will. But then what happens
when we get down there?
Because that's like a line on the earth.
That's the question.
We'll place a bet when it comes to
how you said try taking
him down. Oh, you meant,
I said taking them joy and joy that
when he went down to the ground,
that's not going to win you the fight.
That's true. We could see. Can get,
that would be crazy.
I thought you meant, I thought
you meant that. Uh, um,
he can't take you down. No, not
all day. That looking right.
He'll take nothing for doomed
wrestling's like world world class.
But he'll be looking to get taken
down though he doesn't care.
It's probably better for
him than getting clenched.
So like the sun going to be that easy.
You pull half guard if for
breach over due, but my Jujitsu,
that fucking nasty and Kmarts
gimme against cage with unhook.
Cool bail. I'm jumping to half
guard and we're playing my game.
Suggest suggesting pulling
card. Yes. That's exactly
what I'm telling you, Eddie,
about craziness. Okay, Felipe. No
bare. Meanwhile looking fucking good.
It's incredible. I know, man.
Felipe Novaerus looking good dude.
Good transitions between
striking and the grab one.
You see that video with for Ross
showing how to pull guard like a,
he calls it pulling web web guard
where it's like pulling guard,
but he's gone right for arm bars. He's
just getting right into spider web. Damn.
I'm sorry. Who is this for
us? For to, yeah. Yeah.
He's got a video out. He's
rolling. He's coached. He's really,
we're just talking about, I'm
just telling the listeners. Yeah.
He's really working on pulling guard the
males while not at all pulling guard by
actually doing flying armbars.
That's what he's doing.
He's been flying armbars to pull guard,
so he's setting it up and he's going up
and he's swaying people down and he'll
come their legs and not
necessarily going for the arm bar,
letting you defend using that as a hook
to get your legs and then just putting
you on your back and then finish.
You know,
he's such a good coach when he's really
into that right now who he is so good.
There's no one out there really working
on a point guard by throwing flying
armbars.
It's basically a flying at flying toss
or a flying swim of depending on what the
guy does.
Roy McDonald tried it when he competed
in a Jujitsu match when he was playing JT
tourists. Yeah. Wow. I
didn't see that match.
I know he did really well
and it's common in Jujitsu.
He was willing to get his arm broken.
Shinya Aoki Shinier.
Nokia has a title fight coming up.
Fucking Shinny Oak. He has a
highlight reel of judo. Just met them.
A flying armbars. That's all
monster here. Just stuff in judo.
Just flying armbars in. That's
what Rhonda would do to, yeah.
There's some guys out there and Judah
there aren't going for the throat.
They're going for the flying armbars uh,
Dave Camereo same thing.
I think that they should let a,
okay.
They should've led Aoki where
those fucking tights. I, it
goes, tights are awesome.
I know. They're the best. They
look cool. I know. And it does.
It helps him grip you. Frog. Yeah. I mean,
if you have fucking hand wraps on
you and you have gloves at pad,
you're not going to allow you to punch,
tee off on someone with impunity.
Guy should have some fucking tights on.
Did they still,
do they still allow the wrestling
shoes? No. No more. No Sir.
So long throughout the world.
I'm a fan is how early is it for,
you want him to wear wrestling shoes
and he don't like fake titties.
Crazy. That uh, where
you could wear tights.
They could go up to your knees,
but it's illegal.
If they go to your fucking ankles,
you can tape your ankles.
All right. Right here for
some reason this, this, this,
uh,
the calf and the Shin.
If you cover that with the same material
that you're covering your ass and your
thighs with, if you cover that
part, that's illegal. We'll solder.
Rapo has tried to,
you guys tried to kind of Juke the game.
They had like shorts that go down almost
to the knees than they had knee sleeves
that went over the ankle sleeves.
All you had open was like the calf
and people were complaining, right?
People he was fighting was,
were complaining.
He came out with two knee braces
to ankle braces. Too much bro.
Technical.
They know that's totally legal.
You could wear knee sleeves and
you could wear ankle socks. I know,
but if you need all that shit,
it might be time to kind of move on with
your life. You know what I'm saying?
What are you talking about? That's
like saying tell wide receiver, Oh,
you're wearing gloves in the rain.
It's exactly the same thing.
If Felipe November, it was got his
back man. Damn good. Making gloves,
making gloves illegal in the
NFL. It's, it's exactly, no,
it's not. It's exactly the,
so it'd be exactly the same
thing. Ooh. Think about it.
You're just not thinking about
missing a fucking crazy fight.
Look at this fight looking
Novera tack off of his back.
God Damn. This is a good fight, man.
No, varies. Like really active
off of his back. Oh Shit.
As it gets knocked out,
he's attacking man.
Oh,
it
so close and he got cracked.
Oh Shit.
Shit on my, goddamn. That was it right
there. And he's back. Oh, he's a hough.
Oh, another knee. Dan tries brutal.
No has got some kicks to man.
He throws wild ass kicks.
Here's a set of quads on the Asia
does very good on the ground,
man. That triangle was, that was it right
there? Yeah. If he got some flexibility,
the flexibility, he couldn't cinch it
right away. If he had the flexibility,
he would've sensed it right away that
he needed time to adjust and that guide
them, give them time. He just drove
a shoulder and and broke down.
Just get on that Eddie Bravo program.
Start stretching all the time between
commercials. You gotta be born that way,
bro.
What's funny at Eddie's like I got
insane flexibility saying only in certain
ways and other ways he doesn't like,
like like hamstring
flexibility is a total normal.
I'm like 93 when it
comes to the hamstrings.
This is a good fight. No, very Sean's
and fucking good grappling skills.
It's interesting man.
That Henzel Gracie team.
What a bunch of fucking killers
they've got, Huh? Yeah, man. Hell yeah.
Cummings man. Eddie Cummins is the
Marcella Garcia of leg locks right now.
Really pay attention at that pit cash,
but it's one that we trials finished
everybody for four guy. Nobody can.
He's got leg locks down
better than anybody did he
get everybody would on walks.
Three dudes in Alaska, the arm
barred him. He's a good dude.
He coming right there when Carrington, it
was here. Yeah, that guy. Watch that guy.
He's going to be no, he's the next big
thing. You can't stop his leg. Luxe.
He's John Danaher's
prodigy and super smart.
He's a smart dude.
I can I guess some kind of guy.
Real smart stroke,
physics major type Shit. What
a bitch. I know have it wrong.
It's probably something else.
But in that area,
John Dollars a smart ass and
you're talking to that guy.
They call him a simplest where they call
them. We only has like when a pork. Yeah,
one fork and one fucking
bowl or some shit.
Well he's also got like rules to live
your life by like rules about marriage.
Like I had a Rory on the podcast,
he was talking about daughters.
There's like those rules.
Like the only time you should get married,
the girl has to be under 25. Uh, the
girl has to be more wealthy than you.
Cha the girl has to like,
there's like a whole bunch of [inaudible].
The only way you should ever get married,
it was under these circumstances.
They are like impossible circumstances.
I love the guy, but he's also,
he's also the guy who were a
rash guard and jeans to the bar.
He'll wear a rash guard to a wedding.
Oh yeah.
Where's [inaudible] times roll
your ass up. I'm not mad at that.
He apparently has like something like
really fucked up with his knee though,
which is why he never competed.
Oh Shit. No, just got cracked.
But look at this reaching around.
Oh my goodness.
He's taken some ferocious ground and
pound here knows what the sponsors are and
the
little so okay.
Is when is the Reebok deal kick in?
It's not over there.
July, July. Good guard a cuffed him
too greasy. Look at that.
Everything is too greasy.
One round of one for sure. Wow. I haven't
been paying close enough attention to,
yeah, I don't, wouldn't say for
sure. For sure, for sure. For sure,
for sure. I wouldn't say for sure. For
sure. When am I getting one of them?
Chicken head social club shirt,
like their boss. Oh my goodness.
This ladies and gentleman fighter and the
kid.com the fight and the kid shop.com
it's the, yeah, they're not out
yet though. This is some hot shit.
Can we make a social culture?
I know why Eagle Dick.
When Aubrey was on the show, I see. What
drug did you tell me to do? Watch humor.
I said, we're going to do some
watch human many. Brian goes, yeah,
I'm just turning the eagles with our eagle
software.
Cowen you so silly.
His special May 24th shot at Cowen.
I'm open Irvine Improv.
I know it's gonna be Sodo May 24th and
his first show was already sold out.
There'll be two shows, May 24th at 7.9
priority. I think. Brian Cowen recordings,
comedy special. I don't even
know where it's going to air yet.
I don't think they know.
I think he's filming it and
he's going to sell it to people,
which is sometimes the best way to do it,
to see how hilarious he is and that
way no one will be fucking with it too.
You don't want anybody fucking with the
material. I can't wait minute. Yeah,
we're going to have a good time.
That's going to be fun. The world.
Nobody know how funny that dude is.
He's in right now. He's in New York.
If you were a New York City. Yeah, he's
at Gotham. Gotham comedy club tonight.
Probably sold out. I'm sure he's
been killed. A kid's killing it.
This is an interesting fight,
Phillipe Novell there.
I can't wait for the meeting. Yes, I'm
sorry. Yeah man. Well that's coming up.
Isn't that nice? Magni
first. Yeah. Yeah. Let's see.
We'll go back and you gotta do to
get famous dudes once six in a row.
Yeah, I know. Right? You just,
you see keeps on the UFC man.
That's this day and age.
It's hard to get famous.
There's a lot of people better knocks
on bitches out. Talk some shit.
Somebody said there's 600 people on the
roster now. Is that the right number?
Yeah.
Uh, uh, it seems about right.
Last I heard it was like hi for
hundreds and that was a while ago. God,
that's a lot of fighters.
It's unbelievable.
But bits cause the international scene's
growing like a motherfucker. Ooh,
nice takedown am Lou that
that was a pretty slick take down.
That was no bear working off his back.
What does that guard called Eddie
with the under hook on one side,
like sorta like London and the white
comes over the top. Was it New York?
You know what I mean? When you got
the look. He's in this position now.
The leg comes over the top and
it's not like a rubber guard,
not like mission control. Look at this.
Oh Shit. Is He mad at him? Is that no, no.
I'd have to see it. But you know that
thing that everybody does with a, uh,
like grab it like this. They got sorta
hold on like that. The London is London.
What does everybody else call it though?
There's another name. Shawn Williams.
Guard. Okay. Why is that? Why did
they call it Shawn Williams guy? Uh,
he probably made it up
really, really, I think. Hmm.
But I thought didn't a Nino Schembri
didn't he? Oh, look at this.
Novaerus going for a guillotine.
Guillotine almost to get your writing.
She's going to fuck up.
Get your right knee through sun.
Hit your right knee through. Don't
let him get his fucking body together.
Oh Shit.
You know what I've been doing the
last year about this last week, man,
I did a hot yoga for the first
time in years. She liked it too.
I did two days of this week. Fucking
loved it, man. God Damn. Nothing
bothers me. After that. You go
to a place by your house. Yeah,
I'm sort of started going all the time.
What do you mean method? I like the whole,
I don't give a fuck. You
get out of it. So relaxed.
Not like sore muscles after that.
Oh yeah.
You definitely get a little sore because
there's a lot of crazy stretching
before and then you did it. Would
it cure your soreness? No. Okay. No.
I mean it helped me with,
so it helped me with some of this.
I didn't camp once a week. I love it, man.
It's great to do something more like no.
Yeah, it's, it's really good
for your flexibility. You get
in there. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's the thing. That's
when I think about it, man,
I think just as a relaxation,
there's something about pulling all
the tension out of your muscles,
all the stretching and
all the holding positions.
You don't stress over this fucking arm.
Triangle caught in.
The guards would go 40 arm
triangle. I know, right,
but he's trying to hold that position.
If he's got the super squeeze,
he might be able to pull over shit,
turn away from the case.
You should grab his left leg,
his right turn away from the cage.
Gable grip both hands around the
knee and he'll be totally fine.
There's nothing he'll be able to do
unless you can get that impaler working
right that needed a chest ever
that to break it. Yeah, you could.
Mounting and mounting and me
on the belly will prevent that.
But even the mounts probably even better.
You just get more power if you got
me on the belly, but the mouth,
there's no way he could
defend it from the mountain.
There's no going with jailbreak strikes
me nuts turned tried to jailbreak.
So given that Eddie Bravo, we look
at that very nice. Jailbreak. Nah,
it's only jailbreak if outside control.
That was just him putting
in a butterfly hook.
But the stuff it in like
that good dexterity, right?
You could do that without your hands.
That's one of the differences between a
guy like you and a guy who doesn't have
that flexibility and dexterity.
You do that jailbreak shit and you put
your foot in a way like I would have to
like pull my foot, can be some work,
shove it in there with my hand.
Eddie could do it like whoosh.
Huge advancement in flexible. I've,
I have students that are
way more flexible than me.
They made it doesn't mean you're
not that flexible. I'll kill it.
He's doing it again. That's more
of a jail dude. It looks tight.
It was a jail break and going all the
way across the belly. That's even better.
See how it's turning into it? I don't get
what he's doing over here. It could be.
It could cause she was going away from
judge. If he'd figure for his arms,
it'd be tighter. He's oust and now
he's got one rubber arm for sure.
For sure that,
oh
good look. He got size and trolled,
man. He's went full. Ferocious.
Ferocious. You gotta think
that dude want it? Yeah.
You would think it's serious cardio right
there. He was gone 100% the whole time.
That was a good fight. We
have a yoga channel, Brandon,
if you want to do it like it's your house
really like that Black Swan Yoga TV,
I'd definitely be down to try that.
I kind of need a place to go though.
You know what I'm saying?
Just to commit to it at her.
It's mine that hot and you know,
have the instructor then
you can't take a pose off
fuck off. Usually attractive girls.
So it's motivated now where I go,
but the most important thing, dude, is day
heat. I agree that he needs [inaudible].
You walk in, you're sweating, the moment
you get in that fucking thing, the sweat,
the breath, the stretching and all of
it together. That's fucking hard to do.
Like that's the most amazing thing
about it is how hard it is to do.
And then how relaxed I am when it's over.
Oh my goodness.
All the dudes have all their shirts off
and shit. What I like doing, Jesus, man,
just tidies and guts everywhere.
It's weird policy. Uh,
no. How about your weird,
how about, I'm not for
sure, but your tits. Wait,
I'm trying to do yoga
and get your titties,
my feet and the female memories.
No,
that I'm up for that. It's the out of
shape. Hairy dudes. Those that's, yeah.
You want those in your class.
One guy's,
that guy's less flexible
than you doing shitty poses.
You're trying to compete with them.
Blow my back out and knowing about dudes
that are really good at yoga. I agree.
Thank you man. Fuck you, Bro. I
don't have time to do that shit.
Especially when they're
wearing like ambulance,
ambulance beads are
Lulu Lemon on and shit.
Amulets tight. Yeah,
you stepped my yoga came up though. It
dudes don't wear yoga pants. It's weird.
It's exclusive to women. It's
very, very [inaudible] yoga pants,
all that shit. All that
shit. You're talking shit on.
Why I DDP Yoga? It's
blowing up. It's yoga.
It's not for your Mama.
I think it's not your mom's
horrible slogan. He came out to
honor it and put us all through it.
Some DDP Yoga. How was it? It was
all right. I prefer regular yoga.
I mean you do a lot of counting
and a lot of like hell yeahs and so
the whole purpose can I get a hell?
Yeah,
but not Chicago without the
beads and the incense on.
I liked the incense and B no over one man.
Good for him.
But we weren't paying attention. Yeah, we
just saw that last 37 months. We can't,
we can't really say whether or not anyone
Anik with the new do sexy. Personally.
I'm not mad at suit and tie.
Yeah.
Mixed reaction from the crowd, man.
Sorry son. With all due respect,
I thought the other guy won. It was all
due respect. We were barely attention.
In fact, it was a good
fight. I watched them.
You're argued about
knee braces, Eddie. Hey,
you want to start with that again?
It's not the same. Exactly the same.
It feels exactly the same. The receivers
that I felt would have knee braces on.
No, no, no. This is what it is.
This is why do wide receivers in
the NFL wear gloves when it's rainy.
Why? So they can grip the ball.
They can catch yes and score. Yes.
So they can catch in score.
The same thing with Jujitsu.
It's easier to catch in score when there
it isn't a hot oil wrestling match with
all the sweat and blood everywhere.
Like why is it more manly to fight
and shorts than it is to pence?
That's ridiculous because I don't think
it's more manly. But then why are,
why is it illegal to cover your calf?
That's illegal.
You can't comprehend candid about it.
Exactly. That's what I'm trying to tell.
That's what I'm saying. It's like you
in a sport, you uh, they have meetings.
The heads of the, the football teams
have meetings to increase offense.
They do it in basketball.
What do we do to resolve?
So if they banned gloves,
they made it illegal for a wide receiver
to wear gloves. Those rainy games,
those money. Again, people are just going
to be dropping balls all over the place.
That would be the dumbest rule ever.
They got to do let these motherfuckers
wearing the gloves. The beans are green.
They don't help that.
But pants. Do you know,
blow wide receivers wear gloves
for extra grip? Not all. Most?
Most do.
They do and they do it for extra grip
so they could catch and score and the
league will go, yeah, we want let them if
they, if it makes them score more. Yes,
it's a good plus. They have their spot,
their logos on them. Nike or Reebok. Gla.
I understand, but in an MMA you can
wear tights that go up to your knees.
You can wear shorts but they can't cover
the calf. I agree. That's a stupid rule.
Exactly.
What I'm saying is they,
if it'd be the same if they're
both wearing knee braces,
you should definitely be able to wear
rash guards. Yeah, I think like, yeah,
why not? Why not? Why can't
girls are wearing rash guards
and it's not a problem.
It's not a promise. It's weird.
They won't wear rash guard pants.
They can't wear Ras card sleeves though.
Girls don't fight with long sleeves.
They can on the UFC,
they can't know the short sleeves.
It's illegal. Now.
That's another dumb rule.
Why would that be illegal that
you can't cover your fucking boy?
Magni coming young Goulam 15
look at this rumble in DC.
It's a good fight.
It is a very good fight.
It's just the problem is ultimately
if DC wins, that's really the problem.
That's worst case scenario for the UFC.
Worst case, I want you to win. I want DC.
Do you think that DC, if DC one
like, let's just say DC ones,
do you think that it's conceivable the
DC can improve to the point where he
could possibly beat John Jones? He's
just a judge Jones fresh out of prison.
I'd want to see all groggy and Sean.
No, no, no. Fresh out of prison.
John John's with full camp. No, no,
no one in the world's being
John with a full camp.
No one in the world might be close, but
people would pay to see a fight. Do it.
You got to remember him first. DC. That
wasn't a good fight. He dominated DC.
I gave DC maybe one round
if that dominated them.
Mary took him down his first round. Yeah,
lacked right away. I went right to it
wasn't a good fight, man. John
Jones is a bad motherfucker.
Where do you have another
one of those bars? Yeah, there's a bunch
of the to go in the kitchen, the kitchen,
there's all kinds of bars.
I forgot to bring those away.
I really liked those whey bars.
Those are new ways on May go and get me
a coconut water. Very good. Very good.
Yeah. Give me one of them CTOs to see two
o's. Rumba wouldn't mind at. Interesting.
Fine for Jones because he
can knock anybody out dead.
I think John would have took him down
more and most likely killed or at least
there's a, at least there's
a chance for sure, but,
but we all feel this every time. Oh, this
is guy gotta beat John Wrong every time.
Thanks to that's how good the dude is.
Thanks and thanks for the fuck. Tough one.
Fucked out with the debt I have.
You guys had maple water by the way.
We were about to talk
about this the other day,
but somehow or another we got to talk
to maple water. What is this shit?
It comes from the maple tree
instead of a coconut tree,
just like they make maple syrup but they
make maple water and it's like half the
sugar of coconut water and same like
electrolytes and nutrient tastes good.
It's fucking way better. I can get it
tastes way better than coconut water.
Better. I'm telling you a minute. Then
this coconut water, I was C two O sir.
How dare you. What about that harmless
harvest shit. You ever have that?
That's shit fresh. Look,
I like Coco was good.
It's not Brian Swan is next level shit.
Like if I was a tycoon like William
Randolph Hearst or something.
I buy all the maple trees now. Podcasts
right now. Quickly get on the podcast.
Some fucking maple trees. Yeah, take, we
can't get this maple lines. Just Christ.
I get it at a whole foods and I saw it
at the Paleo conference. Paper water.
They were talking to a couple of
companies because I think it's, it's,
it's next level. Holy Shit. I won the
trip wise. What about it's equivalent.
I haven't done the full gamut of research,
but then what they're saying is that
it's equivalent to coconut water nutrient
wise without so much sugar. Okay. What do
you, what do you think about this fight?
What do you think about, call me. Yay.
And uh, not Courtenay Johnson. Oh,
Weidman versus Belfort.
What'd you think about that fight?
It's a tough call because what bell
force coming in there Belfour off TRT and
getting tested all the time. I don't, I
don't got it right. It's a different guy.
Weidman is a fucking beast.
He is a big piece to me.
How Weidman's not more famous and a bigger
name is crazy. He's so talented, man.
He should be the face of the UFC
out tail to do. Yeah, but he's not
10 you'll call me. Yeah.
Weidman's a motherfucker, dude.
If he beats down Vito Belfort,
it might be,
this might be like a breakout fight
for him. He needs a breakout fight.
You know what I'm saying?
You would think the Machita one would
have done it well if he stopped,
but Cheetah, maybe that would've
done it. True thing is Machida.
Him was an amazing fight, but it
was a five round, amazing war.
It's tough for him because he
beats him silver twice. Right.
But everyone's a cab and
she was fucked around.
There's lake fell off in that other one
and then he gets Leo Machida and that
fell off. It's like back and forth.
But yes, you're right though.
If he destroys veto it and now we've got
a superstar. He's such a good dude too,
man. You know vitarka probably make
welterweight now and I'm not bullshitting.
You saw in Vegas that time? Yeah, well
that was when he was fresh off of it.
When he was fresh off of
it. His body morph, dude.
I mean he lost a shit ton of weight.
I don't remember him hitting Jones,
but they highlighted all times.
He hit Jones,
come on and he's taken John Down.
But that lasted for literally a second
and John was back up on its feet.
You know, you got to look at a guy
like call me a and think I'll also,
he's like 36 or 37 37 37 he's been
competing and wrestling his whole life.
He's only been fighting MMA I think
since he was like 30, right? Yeah.
That loves six, seven years.
We've shot Evans number four. Wow.
Ryan Bader number five.
What are they going to do with Beta?
Well Beta was supposed to be fighting DC.
I know that was a good fucking fight.
Great fight.
I was looking forward and were shot out
for a grip cause he tours a leg again as
me. So he's out for another
year. He's all fucked guests. Uh,
Gus has a global tech Sherif how long
has [inaudible] been out for now?
For a long time. Two years now,
right? Yeah. Two years. Two years.
Yeah. Johnson. He's big tear right
now. Look at this throwing head kicks.
Rashad was telling me Anthony Johnson
owns the spotter practice cause he just
knocks bitches even on accident. He's
like my bad man. It's just what he,
that's his ammo cause he just like,
he goes seeker missile.
Does he go all out or is he just hits
so hard. Just said so God damn hard.
You wonder what's going to
happen to him if he gets pushed.
You know now that he has like he doesn't
have the issue that he had before with
losing all the weight.
He's a totally different now.
But that was the destroyer DC
when you took out pat destroyer.
But um, he was mad at Pat. Pat talked to
a lot of shit just to get the UFC though.
He didn't mean it. He just did it to
get a shot handy to get that fight.
But you know,
I just wonder whether or not he could
take the heat because he couldn't take the
heat at one 70.
He was just so dried out then when he
would like Koscheck beat him that way,
Vito or beat him that way. But as that
one 85 actually, yeah. That's why I,
that's the fight there because if DC can
just get through that first round and
not eat a fucking huge shot,
I think he's just going to wear
Johnson out for eight rounds.
But that's why I think if you
see him against Phil Davis,
he was fucking on 0.3 rounds.
Hard.
Big Difference Between DC and Phil
Davis though. Big, big difference.
Big Difference as far as off
one kid strike to wrestle
fills more of wrestling a
strike and he's not really mixing it up.
Okay, what do we got here and boy man,
come on. I know you're taking magni.
Yeah, got him mad. Really helping.
He does something. I mean get on
the mic. Maybe big talk. Some shit,
maybe get a Scottish accent or some shit.
He's going to have to just keep beating
guys and then become like undeniable.
Now that doesn't work man.
Look at John Fitch. Yeah,
but John Fitch got a title shot.
He did, but he still wasn't that.
He was never like a breakout star one.
Paul.
If he beat GSP would have been a
breakout star shit and he gets asked.
Worked any.
You're just saying this this day and
age and Eoc you got do some shit.
Man is more exciting than Fitz was thick.
Put hands on people.
That's true. Tough as hell. I want to,
I would say it's more exciting
the Fitch because Fitch had some,
some exciting fights. It actually, yeah,
I would say he's more excited and he's
more excited. Neil's thing is he, he's,
he's a point spar touched
up tap, tap, tap, tap, tap.
There's no power is never tired.
I'm never tired.
I called [inaudible]
name forms live gazelle.
I'm still waiting for that to catch up.
Just stick all the gazette.
Nope. It's not hitting
right. Nope. Also famous.
Why all the Gazelle Watkins has already
already exists. Watson. Why Watson?
He's not in the UFC though. He wasn't
the UFC. He fought Tj Dillashaw. No,
I get that, but he's not
anymore. So many pit bulls.
One in the UFC we should put a
cap [inaudible] the pit bull.
The pit bull pit bull pit bull Arlovski.
That's old school man. What I found
was just Andre, what's up Andre?
He owns a pit bull that
he has at least a pip.
Thiago Silva is the pit bull.
Yeah. I see out of this,
but how Laskey was the pit
bull first, right? That's true.
You got to switch up your nicknames.
A few other pit bulls there, man.
There's some other dudes are like,
I would go to get their nicknames at the
UFC and I'd be doing the weigh ins when
I have to call them. I'm like,
I'm not saying that right.
I look at their and I'm like,
yeah you can.
You can't just call yourself some shit.
You know somebody has to actually do.
You can't make up your nickname.
Otherwise I'd be like the Brown nights,
some dope ass shit. You know
what? I'm [inaudible] Brown.
Your Big Brown Callen gave me that
name and all the fans ran with it,
so I had to switch my name so
it's like you don't pick out,
pick some dope ass shit. Like
did you come up with a hybrid?
I didn't come up with it. Again, you
can't pick your fucking nickname.
Who came up with the hybrid, the producers
on the spike. A ultimate fighter.
Why Hybrid? Because they
would a Prius. Yeah. Right.
Cause they had like they would do like
a bed behind the scenes, like don't,
not for money but just like who they
thought was going to win the show and they
didn't know my name.
He's like I'll,
I'll take like that hybrid heavyweight
cause I was at that big compared to the
other guys, but I hit like a
heavyweight. So they called me the hybrid
and then fucking Callen just kept calling
me big brown and kept saying I was
native American and then it's the show
got more popular. It just took off.
I picked the Brown night though,
some Dope Shit Brown.
But you can't pick your nose. White Brown
just cause your, your skin tone. Yeah,
because I'm taking a shit year
round living by the beach.
That southern California
lifestyle bitches.
You really Pale naturally.
Nope. Always been 10 yeah.
I think I'm adopted bro.
It's my family's white as shit.
Super. Everyone's super, super
white and then Brown as fuck.
So you're serious about that.
You're a serious 100% you
don't look anything like your
mother or father neither.
Nothing like that. No. Just kidding. My,
I look like my dad. My Dad's a big dude,
athletic dude, but I'm Brown.
I'm like Kim, but Brown.
Would you ever have any desire to do
this shit, dude? Nah. Oh, you mean, oh,
you mean a fucking drive around?
Nah, I'm good. It looks fun, man.
It would be fun.
It looks fun.
I think it'd be fun to do like the f one
style track students make serious money.
The F one cars are like driving
a like an airplane. You know?
It's all these things like a cockpit.
It's all technical and she has chosen
Alex from a shark works is telling me he's
going to bring down that gt three with
800 horsepower. Oh Mike. He's like, yeah,
he's like huge organ to drive.
I'm like, Nah, I already
drove. Did you? It's manual,
right? Yeah. It's terrible. Good Bro. Do
you know how to drive a manual? Come on.
Yeah, I'm a Puerto Rican man. Fuck yeah.
Don't, don't fucking out of me right
now, Joe. He can't drive a stick. I
A lot was
the other thing that you had on
them there was need Krispy Kreme.
There was one of you could
wear shoes in the UFC.
It's not good. It's not good. Will you
use to be able to wear shoes in pride?
I mean, that's why I like super
old school. I just thought it was,
do you remember when that Brad Kohler
kicked a Steve Jensen right in their face?
Judd, uh, Steve Judson, he
punched him. No, no, no.
Bob Ballou kicked him in the face.
That's right.
Brad stroller doubt Steve Jobs
was one punch. That's right.
It was a haymaker.
Pablo beat his ass and punted
his head and he had shoes on,
punted his head.
He was not that.
You just declare that he is today.
Bob Ballou in the beginning
was a Brazilian wrestler
who could box and he was
fighting to heaven. Nobody like
him. There was nobody like Bob,
like a Brazilian wrestler.
I've always liked Bob blue led boxing.
He's a tough motherfucker, man. You know,
Bob Lou didn't admit to choking that
dude out in his post fight interview.
His whole career would have taken a
totally different turn, you know. Oh,
where he held the choke to lung,
just didn't talk about it.
I was interviewing him. I tried to just
go right through. I knew what he did.
But see there's a difference to me
between the guy who holds a choke a little
long and a guy who holds like a knee
bar a little like, or he'll hook,
we tear someone's knee apart.
That's fucked up. One's career.
One is just in it for Bob allude.
That guy was like talking shit to him
before the fight and he was like very,
very amped up about it.
I don't remember,
I don't remember who it was,
but uh, he was mad though,
put him to sleep and it was
a lot of blood before that.
He'd beat the shit out of him
and then he put them to sleep.
It looked really bad. But I remember
when I was interviewing him, he was uh,
talking about how he did and you know,
and I asked him to clarify
and then people like,
he got upset at me thought like somehow
or another I got him in trouble.
I'm like, dude, you're the one
who brought it up. I didn't even,
I don't even want to talk about it.
I wouldn't have talked about it.
Like he thought I didn't like
him. I'm a big Bible. A Fan. Yeah.
How can you always been
a Bible for me to always,
for some reason he's a fucking
awesome grappler to Matt and amazing.
Really good fucking grappler. His match
with chill frustrated me. But yeah,
he got a Hilti Jitsu Chels during his
MMA career and then like now that's what
he's known. He's a bright
guy, right? Yeah. Dude.
His fight with Dean lister in
Metamorris was very impressive.
He had dean lister locked up. That
shit hurt. Oh, Neil's in trouble. Oh,
he's in fucking wild,
man, dude, man. Oh, snaps.
Just high on just time up brother.
Oh God.
Nasty knee man.
Jesus Christ.
That's a Korean people were tweeting
me saying, this guy's a mother fucker.
He's a wild dude. What did you see
his fight with? Terrick Safa Dean.
He's so reckless.
It was like so wild and explosive.
It's just a matter of he can, can he keep
it up? But magni is just always there.
Dude, here you, whether it's
a storm does cardiac on him.
His cardio allows them to weather
the storm. Yeah. That's impressive.
But the thing is like limb can hurt him
and he yanked me. Can't really hurt him,
you know? Yeah. He just
sussed out point him,
which is a bad game to play with a power
punch or sometimes Maggie's guys back,
we have this,
but he could wear his ass out if limb co
totally empties the gas tank trying to
take magni out prompts a Maggie for
surviving that thought it was over.
Yeah. That dude's swings for the fences
too. He said some really fun fights.
Yeah. He's a big dude man. Right.
Damn. Is she gonna go to commercially
though right in the middle of them round?
Yes. Did it go right in the middle
of the rounds? At the middle of this.
Oh look, they went back. Oh, you
dummies. Whoever's working at Fox.
You're fire Jetson. Sarah stepped
in my office. You're fucking hell.
Fuck. Oh Hell No. Oh my God.
He'll dial back. What happened did didn't
happen. We have no idea. This is a scam.
This is gonna shake. 'Em Off. This is
conspiracy. Eddie Bravo to higher c.
What's the conspiracy on this?
Look at these and Neil Magni a little
too high on them. Way Too high. He's,
he ended up in guard. God Damn it, Neal.
Yeah.
Vcs. Weathering the storm.
Ferdinand Marcos Dylan power.
That was in the 70s Oh,
fucking triangle.
Oh Shit. On top. Very nice. Oh, taxes.
Oh.
Oh stack him.
Got Our chefs are real cock fight.
Come on man.
Neil.
Maggie went to good das.
Could defense at a Thompson Neil's
long.
So those ground and pound
works from way up there.
You have very strict to Sun Mountain.
Oh yeah.
He's very tired. Come on. Damn
Neil. Magdi my close the show here.
Look at this.
Flag them outside.
The body triangle doesn't have it there.
It is.
Got To be one of the most frustrating
aspects of gloves out by how much it it
stops. Chokes stole
full mount again. Damn.
Magna is on fire to maximum mother Fucker,
man.
He really is his guy feet.
Oh Shit.
Oh that dude's exhausted.
He is exhausted but he's still
throwing fucking hammers.
Oh well this isn't good now he's got
magic stack dam but a great fight.
You know.
I mean if he could recover,
maybe he gets exhausted all the time
and then he covered. Here's a good,
here's a good example.
Like who do you give that round two
cause clearly lim had magnet fucked up in
the beginning, but now then magni had
his bag. Malcolm Down Magni mounted him.
I think at the end of the rounds,
more important than the beginning.
If all that shit was solo,
Neil Magni come on strong because of all
the shit I give to the nail right now.
A slight edge.
I'd like the end of the round stronger
to answer your question because if that
shit in the first round was so bad ass,
how could,
how did that guy come back and whip
her ass at the end of the road?
So it was almost like it really,
it wasn't as bad ass as it looked right.
That was a dumb ass.
I wouldn't put it that way.
But I would say that it is more important
at the end because then the two guys
have had the chance to fight and figure
out the strengths and weaknesses and
what's dominating over time.
Over time,
like the ebbs and the flows of the fight
is more important that the guy has the
ability to maintain, can keep it
together all the way through the round.
And at the end of the round, he's the
one who's winning sleight of mouth.
But then again,
limb hurt him more than Magni hurt him,
but it was more dominant overall.
Him had him fucked.
And at one point in time means the end
means like if that was a street fight
right there, I would have said,
Maggie kick his ass, kicked his ass,
kicked kick his ass, kicked his
ass. And you don't remember.
Judges are influenced
by the end of the round.
That's what they're going to remember.
More important to look
at this moment here. Ooh,
this is the end.
But here's the other thing.
Maggie's going to be able to do this
for three fucking rounds. How look,
I mean how exhausted his limb after
that first round we get back nine,
it's sweating. What do,
what such good shape man,
get them cause hell and it's training
in in Denver that training at altitude.
Nope, but look at him. He's
like boom, look at him. Go.
He's just warming up now he's confident.
Yeah. That's his biggest thing, man.
If he can get his confidence inside that
ring, which he's slowly getting there.
You've got a real monster on your
hands and limb is still recovering.
She's still taking some deep breaths.
He's just trying to land
this big shop and look at it.
You can't do that with magnet now
because now magnus is going to wear on it
takes you down though. You're in
trouble. Triple in this limousine.
Exhausted the fact that limb got taken
down like that and then all mount a full
mount with a full four minutes
of mount. Enjoy this. Well also,
the thing about limb, he's shoes,
so that cut is probably brutal.
I said he's a big fellow.
Yeah.
Is Look at this fucking
back mount by Magni.
God Damn Magni full mount again.
Very nice.
Very nice. Other, oh my county's beating
the shit out of them. Look at this.
Goes to, he should keep punching. They're
going to, if you flatten them out.
Oh Shit. Just punch here. There
you go. There to stop the fight.
Quit looking for position. There you go.
Keep going. Keep going. Look at that.
Ref is very close here. Can you feel
the ref when they're close? 100% yeah.
That you start punching harder.
Maggie's ass. That's it. That's it.
Car would listen to stop this fight.
That's it.
Daniel magnate fucked. Yeah. Neil Magni
look at night even breathing. Huh?
Do what? That's amazing. Like 10 more
times tonight. He really isn't breathing.
Where did he try it again?
Denver called altitude high altitude.
Teamhealth handled magnate. How far the,
how often do you go back and train there?
A once a year.
Okay.
That's tough for me to leave that lay
man with everything going on your stuff.
You're right. Nor do I want
to leave. I love La. I ain't
going nowhere. Once steel,
Maggie got ahold of him and that second
round it was total domination and it was
what we said.
Lynn was just too fucking tired.
He's too tired from that first
round and he didn't really recover.
That cardio of Neil magnet is a
fucking weapon. Huge weapon. A weapon,
a huge weapon in the
position he's really good at.
You don't keep him dominant position.
What's going to be interesting about
the main event is both guys have insane
cardio. Uriah Faber has insane
cardio and Frankie's cardio.
It's superhuman. Five rounds.
Just going to be nuts.
I think it's going to be going
five rounds. I don't think so.
I think it's going to be three really.
I think Edgar's gonna take him out.
Wait a minute. The fight, the
fight, five rounds. What is this?
Wait a minute. You think
like couldn't do? Yeah, I do.
Yeah. I mean just based on what,
what happened with cub, you know?
I mean that was savage.
I think he finished Troy.
Yeah. Different Games. A totally
different kind of fighter. Tuck.
Cubs out a wrestle. Your eyes are way
better wrestler. Way Better grappler.
Way More dangerous. Like that comes our
way back as a boy though. The Cub Swanson
is a black buddies. Really
good grappling, grappling,
finishing. As far as finishing your
right favors. Guilty, I would say.
I don't know about that man.
You can't get to your right.
Fame down favor is really good.
Edgy Jitsu.
But Cub Swanson is as well. Look who
has more finishes. My submission. Yeah.
Callbacks to stand and bang. Look at
the way Cup just got finished. Bye Bye.
Max Holloway. She was hurt. He was hurt.
But Max is really good too.
He is really good and when a
guy's her and see you guys hurt,
she gets it goes out the door.
I think it's a good decision for sure.
No one's getting finished.
Couldn't you said some about five rounds.
It's not fiber. It's five rounds.
All made of. It's a fiber.
It's an amazing 2015 Munoz
is the main event. No.
Are you crazy? I think Munoz
is next. Dario. Hey, saucy.
Phillip. Who's the cord? Munoz in
Philippines. Come on. That's it.
That's how no moon isn't even the
co main event. No Man. Musashi.
Philip. Who's Komita that? At least
someone said so. Neil, tell me
he's all, yeah, Gary Condit.
When nine 11 happened,
man, it was getting tough.
The rest and choose one.
It's going to be tough to live
down. Yeah, it's tough, man.
In the [inaudible] comment I gave out,
still get over the [inaudible]
standby for fake titties,
but that wrestling common.
You might want to stay off Twitter.
Just want to pass on social media for a
couple days. What is this? Fight stories.
Favorite talks to
celebrities about fights.
They've been in [inaudible]
favor show. Yeah. Fight stories.
Hope it's all animated. Oh,
that's hilarious. Talented it.
But the story was so vulgar. They
get it. Air It. I was sitting like,
you have to have a different story.
They Kansas story about
New York can beat up cake ass bro.
You can't, you can't share that story.
Wow. And the guy's like, you got to wrap
it up too man. Like this is too long.
They just didn't air. It was, hey, I
got this. A pretty good fight story.
I was in the fourth grade and I were
playing kickball and it was a close game
and kickball and the bell wrong with
someone had kicked a bond and people were
running in and it was like,
well the game's over the bell
wrong dude is still running in.
There was an argument and there was argued
with a fifth grader and his name was
Enrique and I was a fourth grader and
we got an each other's faces. Fuck you.
The bill. Wrong bottle. We won.
And the guy just fucking swift kicked
me right in the balls tied to my knees.
The guy could kick my ass already.
Like I was already afraid of him.
I don't know why it was a hurricane.
There was a an important kickball game.
I dropped to my knees.
Super important, so hard.
All I did is look up and I just
gave him the finger. I said,
and then I got up and just walked up to
the nurse's office and so I was really
fucked. So he poked you? I
was crying, I was crying.
I walked into the nerve nurse's office
crying in the nurse's office still.
And it was that stinging pain more than
it was the ball point tip of the Dick.
Like I should've been bleeding as I pest.
I should have been.
So the nurse sends me home. It was so
bad. I'm a crier was I was humiliated.
And then I find out in the wants to
kick my ass or flipping them off,
but ruthless. But he's going to
have a sport grader, brother,
US CSR do it for me.
So now I've got to fight his brother
because I flipped him off. This guy,
I didn't do shit to him. He kicked me in
the balls. So I'm fucking freaking out.
My brother, the fights going to
happen. Me and SAS are eventually,
so my brother's teaching me how to box.
So we put on some socks around our fist
and he showed me how to sew punches and
I thought, you know what, fuck I
could throw punches. I felt confident.
So we ran into each other
at the, uh, in a, in a, uh,
playground at school. And we got on
each other's faces. And I said, fuck,
just hit him. Just hit him, just hit
him. I was like, I trained for this.
I had confidence and says,
I've got on my train for those.
You flipped off my brother,
you mother fucker.
And I just punched him right in
the fucking stomach and nothing.
He just stood there. I looked
at him, I said, fuck it.
And I just took off and he chased me.
So he's running,
we're running through the school. All the
kids are watching and he's chasing me.
And I'm rolling, man. Until we ran
and I saw the principal, we ran it,
the principal, he stopped us and
he made us do push ups and uh,
and the principal, or maybe you
do pushups for money. We were,
we weren't supposed to be running
through the playground like that.
He didn't know that this guy
was trying to kick my ass.
He thought we were playing tag
or something. Oh, that's so,
so we're doing ups there and he's looking
at me cause I'm going to fuck you up.
And like foam mat.
I had confidence but it didn't
do anything. I punched him with,
I threw the first punch in the
stomach thing, threw the first punch.
That sounds like a bad idea.
Exactly.
And I just ran and I ran and he chased me.
But you know what?
We never ended up
fighting. Uh, it was, um,
I don't know if he gained respect
for me after that. I'm not sure.
But we never ended up fighting.
But Paige vanzant blow it height.
She's blowing up one fight. She's number
seven contender to fights each other.
That's right. Two fights.
Number seven. Whoa.
Women's division was impressed
with her fight with Felice Harris.
She's the judge. She is a fucking
scram. She's a one two cutie pie.
The scrambles Mapper Young,
Huh? 21. Yeah. Damn Brendan.
Ridiculous. And she's turned,
it sends signals out.
Oh,
I'm done with dating UFC
ladies the big brown.
I'm like Walmart with Rhonda, his book,
I don't need that shit in my life.
I'm good man.
You know,
she talks and she taught me, she never
mentioned any names but that wasn't,
you need to be mentioned.
I just heard all the fans tell him he
had a Honda is so fucking huge right now.
You go to the underground,
every third thread is about Rhonda.
Rhonda has superstar. Yeah.
How was that possible?
People are still like
maybe three years ago,
all over the Internet saying women's
MMA will never be big, blah, blah, blah.
This and that. I'll never watch
women's fights and look at Rhonda.
She's arguably the most popular MMA
fighter on the planet. Right? 100% she's,
she's,
she's attractive and she's finishing
girls and 17 second girls that don't know
anything or girls that aren't MMA fans.
They know who Ronda Rousey.
She's crossed over to pop culture
cause she's an entourage. She's in.
Whenever expendables 19 Misha said she
would be willing to fight Cyborg at one
40 Misha said that Sony's has talked to
me, Hsa. Somebody has to sit her down.
She's in at that I knocked loose,
that's like,
you know, which I never noticed
them. I'm not being honest,
but I mean I'm being totally
honest. I used to go, dude,
I used to date a girl at a lazy eye
and I had a lazy eye fetish for awhile.
She was a freak and she was so hot.
It just conditioned to hear.
She was super, super hot and
she had a lazy eye and my head,
I was like maybe like the lazy eye.
It makes her try harder
because she doesn't want you
to bring up the lazy iron,
so she just goes for it.
She's wonderful hot chick.
He gets, I all fucked up. You don't know
if she was looking at your Dick or, well,
it wasn't that Lazy Shit. That's not lazy.
That's palsy. That's a Paul the, I know.
She just had one eye that was like
a little goofy and it was sexy.
I don't know why I didn't read Ron
his book. You wouldn't read it.
Read it 50 times already
about reading anyone's biography neither.
I'm all set on that. I mean, I've,
I've read biographies in the past,
but you have to do some fucking Nikola
Tesla Shit to get me to read your
biography. If every, some epic shit.
I'm all set on reading fighters
so much about her, her a career,
you know. Oh Shit. Mark
Munoz. Yeah. They play here.
Count down every other weekend if
she's fighting or not. I'm all set.
Powerful. Mark Munoz. I really
do. I mean, I really do hope
he wins this. Me Too, man.
Such a good guy.
Literally the nicest guy ever.
I just like to see him go
out with a victory and that's
already beat Damien Maia
tat was, uh, Abu Dhabi. The Tim
Boetsch one was a big win. Huge win.
He's coming off two losses. Yeah.
And then, and then he got Leo.
I'm a cheat on short notice. He
got kicked in the face. Yeah.
And Moose Saucy beat his ass. Tom
saucy looked really good in that fight.
And then I hope he wins
this big and keeps fighting.
Pawn Carnero just choked him out.
I
Hood Barnett just lose too.
I thought I was surprised by that.
I thought that he's lost two by decision.
By not wants to, yeah. You know, mark
a shutdown, a reign training center.
Rain is no more. Yeah, he's,
he's retired, right? Yeah.
But it doesn't mean you have to shut
down the gym. Really expensive download.
Is that what it is in suits?
Well for mark it was just,
he just wants time with his family.
Like you said,
I think he's sick of being in the game.
Well, like when you say real expensive,
like how much per square foot? Oh
Shit. Not where he's at. Eddie.
I don't think 50th. Really? I don't
know what you're looking at. Me.
I'm asking this because you looked
at a bunch of places, right?
Like you're looking at, uh, places.
I have never looked down there.
That's too far down south. Okay. I
don't know what it would shut. I just,
that's what I heard people were saying,
why did he shut it down by Blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah. Then people will just
not killers, they expensive. He just,
the time commitment was a beast was taken
away from his family. How he lost it.
Lodge Roger Narvaez. Yeah,
that's what it was by that.
And then before that he lost
a Sean Strickland. Dale. Yeah.
Two split decisions in a row.
But before that he beat
Matt Nelson and uh,
Andrew Craig. That's a
tall order for Luke. Yeah.
Luke's a favorite and that's,
I think is he really,
well that's just because Munoz has
lost a bunch. Just monsters though.
That's fucking monsters. Machita Musashi's
a far cry. You know what I'm saying?
To the competition that
Luke's been facing. Sure.
Mark's thing is he gets so
out of shape him between camp,
so his camps spent just get them to lose
weight instead of focus on my game plan
and then he's running a gym and then
he has whatever, 19 million kids,
you know what I'm saying? So the dude
was always like worn out. How many kids?
He has like seven. I think he's set six
or seven. The entire population of Canada,
19 million. It's all, those are all
my kids. Again caught of our time.
He's like fucking Sean camp.
That's what he does, man.
How many kids is Sean camp had shit.
I mean not 15 and like 15
baby mamas. Really? Yeah. Wow.
It's so crazy. What are you, you, you'd
think after three baby mommas that, gosh,
I bet this shit rich that he probably
thinks is 90 more cause he broke.
I'm sure Sean camp 15 baby mamas,
but that guy made like a sports bar.
I went to a sports bar in Seattle.
It was shit. Hey, I'm going
to Google. Sean camp broke.
What do you mean he needs to shitty worn
down from his chambers bay as a sports
bar.
His sports bar
we'll change was rough looking 50,000
women and got only a couple of them
pregnant interest. Good record. Yeah.
How it was still wilt the still,
he's retired. Shawn's retiring shot.
Super retired,
but that's not good because when you
have all that money that you have to put
out and then you home,
none of it's coming in and you also
like shiny things like shiny things and
fatty acids. It's a dangerous
Combo, man. It gets ugly.
You can buy Shawn Kemp socks now
from stance. Oh, that's true. Right.
Sean Candace Seattle Supersonics. I'll
take a pair of those persons is not broke.
He didn't sort of broke like, but he
gets like some crazy annuity. Right?
He's not that, that documentary is
coming out. I just got interviewed.
He said that's just a myth and like he's
doing just fine but wasn't there like
him begging for money? It was total
bullshit says that's not true.
Well there's difference between like
regular person broken famous broke.
Cause Mc Hammer told me like, you're
almost like, oh mc hammer went broke.
He was like,
I wasn't broke us at three mills.
Shawn Kemp made $92 million.
Well, the crazy eyes here,
how he lost his clothes,
but here it says how he lost it all.
Yeah,
he bought Iraqi dinars so he is broke.
Um, this is a shitty
website here. It says, um,
okay read the story of Sean Camp could
potentially save you $100 billion.
The sonics forward fathered at least
seven children by six women lost most of
his career earnings to child support
is post NBA life has included failed,
come back,
attempt multiple drug possession arrests
and the ultimate athlete rock bottom,
playing against a stocky sales
reps on pros versus joes ish.
Wow. Okay. This is just a dickhead
website. This is a dickhead website.
They're trying to be snarky. Do you
remember Cromarty and his kid? Oh yeah.
Oh yeah. Well he had five and
five, right? Way More than that.
12 or something like that.
He's the only five. Dude,
you're fucked when you have different
baby mamas and you got to pay him and he
got it. Because you've got
to maintain that lifestyle.
It's your income at the
tub. Right. But it's also,
it's not just one woman
that has all your kids,
which would probably be better for them.
No,
they say this the fast way to go broke.
Bad idea, man. Wrap it
up. I'll get tricked.
Some dudes just don't give a fuck.
Just none in people.
But how many can I say? You have
six kids. Just like, what the fuck?
Yeah. Well, it's just,
I think some people,
it's like part of the fun doc and
chicks have been life on the edge.
I think they like it. You know that
you'd have to after after four years,
just like fuck this
looks relaxed and happy cause he looks
the last time he's going to walk out
there. I was just so, you know mark real
well. So the, the grind of the training,
it's just real hard on him. Mom Super
hard. And He uh, he just blows up, man.
Why does he blow up? What
does he, he loves to eat. What
does he eat? And he's like,
Filipino food.
He's eating like shitload of rice and
fucking so he's going to get good marks.
He retires, Huh? Oh,
I would be willing to bet mark
will be 300 pounds and three years.
If I was a betting man, which I am
all of a sudden get in the ring.
It was like Pam, he's almost
Siemens show it. Right.
He was checked out and boom is,
he's in the ring and there's tall Luke.
Yeah. Help me. That was my, that Luke.
It isn't that weird. Super Weird,
but it was just weird how they just did
that because they showed him like taking
his jacket off and then like
within a second he was in the rank.
That must've been switching.
She's my cage. The octagon.
Yeah man. Uh, Mark Mark, he did.
His thing is, is he's always just,
he's losing all this
weight given shaping camps.
They can't focus on the game plan.
Like we would spar and he would be doing
like a six mile run before in covenant
spar. Like what do you do in men? This
Sparwood just shit. Just to lose the word.
Yeah, because he'd have to loose
weight, spar and then do the run.
He would want to train it.
You'd have to run after two and you'd
have come back at night to reign and do
conditioning. Cause he, he was so behind
the weight all the time. That's so crazy.
That will beat you up.
Yeah man. He was exhausted.
That's terrible for you
or injured all the time.
Then he was injured all cause the
body gets worn out. It probably,
overtraining tried to lose that weight.
You need to go to fucking Yoga Sun,
get some hot yoga in your lab.
That to get some yoga in my life today,
I'm a big fan all sudden again.
I haven't taken a yoga class in years.
And then I took two this week.
I'm loving it and he stepped my game up.
There's so much yoga where I'm at too.
Yeah, there is. That's yoga central.
It is the west side to buy a mat.
It's all fucking full obs,
lemon pants. So flip flops
and big acids to Powell. Yeah,
I'm not mad at that, but I'll tell you
what man. That whole yoga booty not real.
Okay. Like you kind of get a little
bit of a, but you want to get a,
but you got to do deep squats. You lazy
but hit them. Squats, squats. Well squats,
dead lifts and don't let anybody tell
you any different. Oh, I have my,
I have my girls squat and shit. Shit,
loads or rice. Just build that ass.
Just not a carb. The time,
just carb load for that.
Here we go. Come on Marky mark.
Let's see that donkey. Fast,
fast and tall. Light on the feet.
They said he's six. Six. Good Lord.
It's a tall drink of water. Light
on his feet. He does. It looks good.
It looks good on his feet here.
I like Luke a lot, but I really,
he has a whole career ahead of monies and
Munoz is going to be super
motivated coming into this.
Don't not want to go on that now.
Hell No.
Munoz got some fucking real power man.
Real power
dude. His wrestling and transitions
nasty. So train with them two weeks ago.
He's looking great. Did he come into
this camp overweight as well? No,
he came in better shape. This
camp. Oh, we just had a knee. Oh,
he's getting [inaudible]. Oh Shit.
It's not going to happen, mark. No,
he's a beast. Was guilty. He's
transitioning. Move in. Oh Luke.
Very gooey mark down here as a
monster man. But Luke so long.
Yeah.
Look,
mark has been going with Kendall
growth to get ready for how long he is.
Oh really?
Yep.
Perfect training apartment mark is
nasty with his ground and pound ground
pounding. It's absolutely fucking
ferocious and he's sick. Wrestler,
dragged him to the ground.
Who this is?
This is Mark's fucking home base here
against the cage on the side here.
He's so good man.
Okay.
Lukey so long and tall. And Lucas
from England, right? So yeah.
Doesn't have a background in wrestling,
but he's trained that alliance,
so he's going some tough guy. Right?
Alliance is a fucking Hell of a gym, Huh?
Hell yeah. But they really put together
some camp down there in San Diego.
Yeah,
they did.
Oh Shit. We got per cut then
he's going to shoot. Oh,
he's just trouble.
Trouble. He's in trouble.
Mark with under underhook
trouble. Well, look with, oh,
you tagged them again? Well, you're
my boy mark. Just feeling it.
Don't hit a knee.
Take them down. Marky mark. Good Body
Shot. Yeah. Oh, you own down son.
Oh, nice. I was nice. Mark.
Get them outside. He's so good here,
man. It's right there. Oh, missed it all.
Mark worked on his cage work. It's
does. He just does tons of cage work.
He's so good against the cage.
Organizes his camp.
And why did they ever
let him get that fat?
That's the prom with mark running
reign training center for a long time.
Mark was doing everything.
He was running his own camps too.
He's running his own camp and then he'd
coach me and whoever else was in there
while during his camp and when mark was
fighting Weidman, I told mark, I said,
hey mark, what do you think?
Why these doing right now?
You think he's coaching other guys
is he's getting ready for you.
But mark just loves it, man. He loves
the give back is such a nice guy,
but it caught up with them. So,
um, what do they do with rain?
They just closed the doors. It's all,
yeah, they closed the doors. Oh Shit.
He's hurting a man who keeps her room.
Look at these.
You drag them right back down the Alaska.
Him Now mark was growler cane with cog.
Well his ground upon is like at a very
high low. That was a big right hand man.
Oh Shit. Hammers that. He's on fire
right now. How can you not be men? Yeah.
Oh, we just got to watch
that. I watch shows up,
kicks watching like he's trying
to go della Hiva on him. Oh,
just barely miss and Marky mark. Oh
God. He's gotta be careful. Yeah.
That knee and the transition.
That'd be heartbreaking, man. Yeah,
he's looking so good right now. This
class afield. Davidson Barnett's corner.
Yeah. It's kind of too late to have that
good of a wrestling coach if you can't
wrestle. You know what I'm saying? Can who
do that? That makes me laugh. Why is it,
oh, you said that he took him
down. He did a great trail.
I'll look at that. Look at that.
Beautiful escape. I Munoz. Oh Shit.
Ooh.
He's hurting a minute ago.
Body. He's walking him down. Look at this.
Completely walking him down.
Hands up.
Marky mark is too long
to be doing that shit.
Okay.
Barnett is exhausted. How's marks? Cardio?
Pretty good know we have
that wrestling background,
especially when it comes to grappling
and grapple all damn day just in his DNA.
So He's got to start coaching wrestling.
Is that what he's going to do?
He does wrestling camp.
Oh,
he does wrestling camps and then his son's
a stud wrestler and he wants to focus
on his family. Man. What is he going to
do for a living? That's a good point.
It's a great question,
Joe. You got 100 kids.
You've got to really take that
into consideration. 19 million.
Joe is not like he um, made enough
money from his UFC career to retire.
He absolutely not. And then you're
giving up your school. Well,
his school, was it making money? Not the
money pit was it? He was losing myself.
It's hard, but he, you know, he
does, he does speaking engagements.
He gets paid for that. Yeah, he does all
that. He does an anti bullying program.
He does wrestling camps.
I'm sure mark Mark's a smart guy.
He's wife's super smart.
I'm sure she's going to help him out.
I'm sure he has a plan. Guarantee it.
I hope so. I just don't know the plan.
So Blue Barn had loses.
Is he out three and out?
Is that the rule or is that not only guy?
Depends on the guy.
It also depends on what the
fight looks like. You know,
if you fights like this wild crazy ass
fight that might keep them around just
because it's,
I mean it takes two to tango guy
was willing to throw down like that.
Like that was what kept Dan Hardee around
and Dan Hardee was losing it was like,
yeah, he might be losing, but this
mother fucker throw Garcia. Oh yeah.
I mean he lost a shit load of fights.
I think foreign row five row Leonard
Garcia would throw rocks. Every premise.
Hips throwing rocks, just old
school from his hips, right? Yeah.
He was wild. And here we go. Round dose
in the Philippines. He's got some Super
Filipino power being in the Philippines,
fight in his last fight, nicknames,
a Filipino wrecking machine.
When went the crowds like their
first big UFC in the Philippines,
first UFC ever in the Philippines. It's
probably not quiet like the rest of Asia,
right? Yeah. But it's different,
but it's different. Yeah,
definitely that like a hand, right? Yeah.
Well is there a different kind of Asian,
it's interesting.
It's Spanish and Filipino.
They all have like Spanish last name
or excuse me, finish and Chinese.
They have Spanish last names.
It's like a lot of really similar
like, uh, like one of the,
the greatest pool player of all times.
The guy named Efren Reyes
from the Philippines.
But I mean that sounds like a Mexican.
Yeah.
Afrin Raeann Mexican Mark
Munoz friends Mexican. Yeah.
Booster
is another guy.
Munoz with the clinch
fucking cardio man is so much of fighting.
That magnified.
Proved that, huh? True.
That skills for sure.
But the limb that came out and tried
to win that fight in the first round,
not the same limb,
so tall,
so tall and well coached. Oh Shit.
Gotta be careful. Those fuck the elbows.
Brown elbow. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. He
said the kind of the blueprint for that
is keeps tagging Munoz
too. Oh, she, no. Oh Shit.
You know, fight people are talking
about on that DC card is a Oh,
[inaudible] brown.
Oh yes.
That card. Oh my God. A card is
so insane. That card so insane.
It's like there's too much to talk about.
Donald Cerrone moaning on the air against
who had to get a replacement. Who,
who's just reflect Canadian
cap from Tristar. Oh yeah.
John Mc Dessie. Yeah. Yeah,
because Habib number Grumet.
I've heard his knee again.
Pet has hurt his fucking arm. Really
bad man. His elbow, right? It's his arm.
His fucking mangled.
He got taken down.
His arm got trapped in the cage like
during the take down these you got some
pretty significant damage.
It's a bummer. Yeah,
it's a real low. The uptake
was to touch the triangle. Yes.
Munoz is really good ground and pound
from the guard to, yeah, really good.
His passing is getting good too.
He's been working with Casey Halstead
from 10th planet, Costa Mesa a lot,
so we got to get a 10 plan in an Austin,
bro. I don't decide where my schools go.
They just, the city's designed,
you know what I'm saying?
There has to be some dude who's obsessed
with mastering the 10th planet system
and whatever, and his mission in
life has to be to open up a school.
Those are the only guys
that can pull it off. Yeah.
You're not doing them halfassed
yeah. Yeah. You can't go to like,
I need to anybody interested in
doing this 10th planet stuff.
It's a good system done by you.
You can't sell it.
You got to have someone that's already
into it while just get someone who's into
it and our sell Austin to them
about work. Do you want to train?
Is that what's going on? But yeah, it'd
be fun man. Todd whites down there. Yeah,
I'm going to do a seminar. They're pretty
Santiago. I, it's helped me up at school.
You met Todd white before.
Nice famous artists. Dude,
the great dude want to John Jocks, black
belts, old training partner of mine.
He just moved to Austin and he loves it
there, man. He's raving to me about it.
People Love Austin. Huh? To great town.
It's one of the best towns. Got Country,
man. I played football there, but
I've never like hung out. You ever uh,
do the Alex Jones show now he's ever
brought John and I see him all the time
though. You see it just randomly.
He's super marketing. Are you serious?
No, I see him. He's downtown a lot.
Does he recognize you? Yeah. Yeah.
He's an interesting dude. He's
all divorced up now. What? Yeah.
He got an apartment in a building that I
didn't know he got divorced helicopters.
Wow.
He's a wild man now.
What are the weirdest things ever
was listening to an Alex Jones,
a voicemail on my phone
when we were in Vegas.
We were hammered the night before
just listening to my messages.
It's Alex, Jonah, Eddie, uh, I dunno
what you guys are doing. I can't do that.
Alex Jones. It goes all the
last time. I was pretty crazy.
You guys are going to get breakfast.
What time should we meet for the fight?
We brought them to the UFC and kind of
highest fuck up block cookies. Oh Man.
You know that guy. That guy is. I was,
I was wondering if he'd be sick of
talking about conspiracy theories. Like,
I mean he does a show where he'll talk.
Conspiracy comes fucking thoughts me.
He wouldn't stop. He won't stop you
love. I loved it. Every question.
I had some document.
Well we have the documents if you go
back to, but when Truman was an office,
this is all put into place and
I'd ask him about that. Back then.
I was really into,
I was super into Ufo and stuff back
then and I was asking him about that.
He goes, if he was into it and he's like,
that stuff that we can't prove it. I'm,
I'm, I'm focusing on what we can do right
now with the people, the United States.
I'm not focused on space,
focus on the government and Tam and
he like to talk about space, you know,
you don't killed, you. Oppose
for me is ancient aliens.
After a couple of seasons of that,
I'm like,
I don't ever want to see
anything on Ufo was again,
you know what killed it for me is
talking to people. And when I did that,
Joe Rogan questions, everything, you
know, talk to the experts. I was like,
where's the evidence you got now you guys
got enough and no one has any, nothing
massive evidence that's about,
there's massive evidence,
but we don't have the cameras to film.
Like, it's always like, you know,
there's always these new films if you
will fall as you get on youtube every day.
Bullshit.
But would have,
it's what they actually were spacious.
What would it actually look like?
It would look like a little dot.
No one has cameras that can
capture shit the government does.
And I think honestly,
if someone can come here from an o
clock and planet damn big right here,
someone can come here from another planet.
They could be a rubber Dick and the Scott
silver shift. It could be cloud, it
could be anything to be in total. No one,
it looks sensible.
Assume what it looks like.
They're really close to making
an actual cloaking device now.
Like if you ever see those
Japanese jackets where the
entire jacket like films,
what's behind it? Yeah. Like it's so it's
amazing. Somebody should impossible. Yeah.
Like you are wearing a jacket, right?
And the jacket literally will be, uh,
an accurate representation of behind you.
And it's like real crew technology.
It's like a screen,
like your jag would be a screen,
like say if we were looking at you and
your chicken head shirt was in fact that
the background, the camera, the
whole thing. But it's behind you.
Like Dave Verde figured out how to do
that, but it's kind of crude. Well.
Eventually there'll be able to do it
where it's indiscernible from the sky,
like you'll be moving through the sky.
Like Predator members.
The creditor has that Shit. He
would just, it would wiggle,
but you'd see the wiggling.
I think they're going to have that.
You know that kind of technology for
sure within the next decade or two and
aliens probably have that. If they can
get here, please give it up on the screen.
Look at it up there. This
is pretty dope. Look,
this guy's got this thing on this cape.
Now Watch what happens when they
turn it on. It's pretty slick, man.
The guy standing there with this thing
and it allows them to project everything
that's behind it. I don't need to
see all that. Yeah, here we go.
So look at this and that. Crazy. Look
at that. That's a real, it's not nuts.
I mean I can for sure still see them,
but yeah, that's what's crude right now.
But it's, it's going to get
to a point. Get there. Yeah.
It's going to get to employ it in a few
decades where it works and they could
put it on airplanes and shit. That
was pretty cool. That was pretty good.
Special Effects for back then in Predator.
I can still watch that cause a lot
of that shit doesn't hold up at all.
You can't watch clash of the titans
without it being silly right now.
You watch a bunch of stuff like this,
some bullshit flutters legit,
but I was just bummed out that they're
fucking, they're thermal technologies.
So shitty. All you have to
do is cover yourself in mud.
I know I can't see you come on son,
and you're still warm. I agree.
They'll just get to be boring.
But what about of your eyeballs?
That's the best [inaudible] ever see me.
Come on and do it and you see me now.
You guys seem mad, Max. I
heard it's amazing. I knew one,
I heard the new ones in my,
like Tom Hart. Is it suck?
I can't say that on a podcast.
Yes you can. A kid. Does it
suck? How bad is it? Suck.
It's terrible. Oh my God.
Everybody says it's amazing.
I want to see a 90 on rotten tomatoes
the first time I saw it. Go see it then.
Is it that bad? You know, we
probably have a lot of shit. He,
Eddie Bravo and I do not agree on
movies. Some movies, some movies.
But when it comes to
like comic book movies,
this motherfucker hates it when you know
that the dude who's the star is going
to live. I can understand. I
can see that. I could see that.
We would go to the movies. We
would go to Bloomie's. I fucking,
I knew the whole time he was going to
be fine the whole time. I'm like, dude,
it's a comic book movie.
Can't kill spider.
Run that killing iron
man in an iron man movie.
So what's your favorite comic book?
Movie jokes?
Like which some of your favorites. I'm
a big fan of the hulk. I love the hawk.
Just cause I love the idea of a fucking
nerdy dude. Bad Max. Look at that.
Nine out of 10 and IMD be 99% of
people move those things out dude.
It was terrible. It was like,
it was like the warriors,
but instead of just killing Cyrus don't,
same day check
his house. They took his house and then
now Cyrus is going after the warriors.
He's alive now cause they took his
own. Tom Hardy. Does it make it go?
One of them was pregnant this
month of our warrior movie.
That worry movie was dog shit.
How dare you,
our friend Brian counts and then hear you
Jamie. You're not Mike. You fucked here.
A guy named producer and
you're talking to the back.
That was a terrible movie he was
in. Okay. What'd you say it? Oh,
is it one of those? Uh, you had a side?
No, nondisclosure. Jamie goes to the,
Jamie's one of those focus group people.
Have you find out why movies get
changed to talk to Jamie to, okay,
I'm going to tell you one of those two.
Critical and shit. He loves that couple,
I guess. Yeah, there's a guy,
there's like these different gangs
of a warrior. Oh look at this. Oh,
Munoz with the takedown. Munoz.
Definitely one of this fight by the way.
Three of three.
Yes.
Eddie don't really mad max for me.
I'm not going to ruin it for her.
I'm just going to tell you, don't get
tried to character. Do not get tray.
There's a character who play there.
There's all these uh,
you know,
a Dune buggies and all these cars with
all these guns and these warriors,
they're like gangs,
right? And one gang has,
they have a truck with all these apps
on it. A truck. There's a wall of amps,
a truck that the wall of amps and they
have a guy playing guitar in front.
So whenever they go to battle,
there's a guy in the front
of the trailer in the guitar.
It makes me want to see it.
That sounds awesome.
That sounds dope.
The whole time you blanket and
it's like hit that truck of a wall.
It's a truck with a wall of amps.
Oh my God.
It's hanging in front of that sounds
amazing guitar. Yeah. I want to see that.
Why is it that you sold?
That's great.
Thank [inaudible] on rotten
tomatoes. 99% I know, man.
I don't know you a 1% or is that what's
going on? Yeah, it is. It sounds fucking,
it was just, you know what
if you, if you see it,
I stay. I stayed. I didn't
think it was so ridiculous.
It was like a cabin in
the woods type movie.
It's so ridiculous that it's like,
well,
you didn't go to it because you thought
it was realistic and shit. Right.
I Love Tab.
I don't mind day.
Are you the guy that goes to transformers
and like, I hate transform robots.
Can't tell him I don't even go.
You're not going to catch me there.
I'm not
a movie about kids toys.
Robots.
Oh, okay. Yeah, I agree.
I haven't seen one of them transfer.
Need that Michael Bay.
I'm sure he's getting mad pussy,
but I don't like his shit.
I don't like that. End of that
shit. I don't know who did it.
Did he do the Ninja Turtle movie? Who
did the Ninja Turtle? Michael Bay did.
Nobody saw that shit. What
you saw three times? Always
somebody to turtles.
Ninja Turtles. My fucking
four year old. I'm not old.
She has Ninja Turtle. She's
awesome. She's awesome.
I hear the same shit when I was a kid.
You guys are just older than me.
Ninja turtles or the fucking
just older than me. No,
we're just not retarded. No.
Your turtles. Turtles Dude.
Even if I was fucking 12 I wouldn't
be into a turtle. Yay. All right dude.
Cowabunga what the fuck?
Just no, no, no. They,
they're,
they're business.
They have a rat that hangs out with them
and he teaches her. Where did he learn?
He didn't even fucking say where
he learned it. Where's this?
They did some fake Dojo. He's a MC
Dojo guy. Oh, he's like teaching kids.
Whose teaching rats. Who is he training
with? Is he getting any sparring in?
Oh yeah.
This is the one thing not might
get back down to do with age.
It could be eight years old.
I would think. Ninja turtles
are stupid. It's fucked.
Do you know how long do you like Charlie
Brown? Charlie Brown. Oh wait, cartoon.
Did you grow up with? Um,
what did I really like?
I was big on like the road
runner bugs bunny cartoons.
Cause it was a lot of violence.
Super Love Ninja turtles
are fucking Ninja Turtles.
You know what's in their teenagers.
You know, it's interesting. I know,
I know you were into it, but
you know, it's interesting.
I've been watching the old, um, they
have all the old Popeye's on iTunes.
Those are dope dude. They're
so fun. First of all,
the style of animation is so weird.
Powerful.
Mark Munoz winter now to cry man. Cause
he's retiring right now for him. I hope.
I wish. I wish I could hear it.
Yeah. Crank it up. Jamie lives here.
So get back to Ninja Turtles.
Cheers man.
Congratulations.
It's not the car
he speaks.
Tagalog is not fluid at all.
No.
I want to say I love you.
My beautiful wife.
It's gotta be a hard speech.
Right.
You know, from the day when I was
a kid, I was watching cartoons.
Okay, this is going too long
already watching, cut him off
the truck. That's a truck saying right
now for sure. His last fight, he don't,
he don't give him the mic and you
don't let him talk about cartoons.
The Philippines. Yeah, for sure.
Let's just Ninja Turtles for sure.
Have a plan before you go in there.
A lot of things guys. I tried to
be a moment for sure. Retiring
could come back.
Yeah.
It's gotta be so hard also to have a
fucking hard three round fight like that
and then give a big speech. Right. Damn.
I thought it was going to say retired.
He's not going to know he's retiring.
He didn't take his gloves off and leaving
them in there. No. Oh, here we go. John,
you'll come up with the performance of
a lifetime as you take the gloves off
here on the on and off for the final time.
Eddie message for sure.
Just cut the clothes off your ear that
the foremost gentleman in arguing as
classy as it gets it and
obviously what a way to go out.
Any final message for the fans before
you hang them up for good? You know,
this is something I've
dreamed about and I hope for.
I know I didn't accomplish what
I wanted to accomplish in a cage,
but I visit a lot of my time in lives
and I invested in in their treasures,
in their heart and I've been able to
help change lives and impact lives in a
positive.
I'm here for and I have a story how the
story again be able to give to kids and
I want to be able to teach and come back
here to the Philippines and be able to
get my talents,
gifts and abilities to you guys.
I'm being able to help the Philippines,
it wrestling and that's my goal.
Guys. I have, I have so much.
This is such a good coach too.
Putting my gloves in the center of the
octagon because I got so much love and
admiration for the support.
Thank you to the best organization
on the planet and mixed martial arts.
Thank you.
You have a c thank you.
Don't leave frank out. They
fucked up leaving frank
outside Franks at home going,
what the fuck? Right? I
own 40% of this bitch.
C'Mon. C'Mon this fucking
guy. What if I'm frank?
No frank
and frank for from
this fucking guy. Right, so fuck this man.
Glory.
Yeah. You're going to have to wrap
this up, mark. You Ma. I love you man.
Fucking wrap itself, Bro. That's,
that's good. You know what?
You don't how he said he didn't
want accomplish we one too.
I had a talk with mark before he fought
and I told him he can't look at things
that way, man, because if we, if we,
if you wrap up your career and say,
because you're not the world champion,
your career was a failure, then 99% of
the fighters in the world are failures.
You can't look at it like that.
Mark has had a great career. I said,
if when you were in
college and I said to you,
you're going to have a seven or eight
year career in the UFC and be one of the
most famous middleweight in the world,
what would you say?
He's that guy I would have
sent out as successful career.
I said exactly just because
you didn't get to the belt.
Does it mean to you to have a successful
career no matter what your record is?
He's had a very successful people think
that way about life in general though.
You'll have a relationship with somebody
and it doesn't end in marriage and
they'll be like, oh yeah,
that was a failure. It wasn't
a failure. You guys had fun.
You probably learned years. He learned.
You like know, like it's not a failure.
Just a lot. A couple of xs. I
need you to talk to him on that.
Ah,
and back to his Ninja Turtle Shit. All
right. How dare you. Don't do this.
Don't I grew up on fucking Ninja Turtles,
man. I want to show you some of the,
should pull up some old Popeye Jane
would get my Ganja Donatello's sense.
Pull up some old pop by. This is one
of the things that have been noticing.
I have it too. I'm watching
Popeye with my kids. First of all,
Popeye was sponsored by the NRA.
How crazy is that at the beginning
of some of the Popeye episodes,
there's an ad for the National Rifle
Association, which is very strange.
And then to Popeye is violent as fuck.
Bluedot is always trying to rape olive
oil and everybody's beating the fuck out
of everybody.
It's racist as shit.
There's some stuff with Indians and
native Americans were Popeye's beaten up.
The Indians, they're shooting arrows at
him. Dude, you got to watch like what the,
the way they move popeyed meets
Sinbad. Like, look at the way they,
they have like a little
wiggle to the way they move.
They don't just stand there
like, uh, like, like, you know,
like a normal cartoon dot. Yeah.
Constantly. They're dancing,
they dance,
they go left and right and right and left.
Did you grow up on the Shitty, you just
got into it? No, I didn't really, I mean,
I guess I saw it was a little kid
and you guys are into this shit.
I wasn't into it.
I wasn't in total and Jerry's,
I'm looking at this as like
a time capsule. Like the,
I didn't look at it in terms
of, uh, other constantly moving.
Yeah.
Everything is moving.
Everybody I want to see pop by himself
and all these dragons and shit.
That trillions pretty legit.
Yeah,
look like they kind of have
like a little wiggle to them.
And this is the color version.
Pluto huge mouth. Yeah.
What's interesting is like
pop by, uh, started off,
it was a black and white
thing like Betty boop. Yeah.
They're the early s the early series.
Do you ever see Robin Williams and Papa?
Yeah, he was good. He was
really good. That and uh,
what about him smoking
spinach to his pipe?
What about that leaf blower?
A leaf blower. Oh my God.
We're in the wrong spot.
That's ridiculous.
Did have a drummer next to my studio.
We had so many podcasts with
drums in the background. I do.
Last time I did you think, did you
step away from doing your, your, your,
your stops rolling?
Yeah. Yeah man. I'm just
ran out of guests. Ran Out
of gas. The gas. Come on.
I just need some time to chill for awhile.
Yeah. Yeah. You need a break cause it,
yeah, just needed. Just a
little break. And you feel
like it was an obligation? No,
no, not at all. What was it
fun anymore? No, no. It's
very fun. It's still for sure.
Keep doing it then.
Why'd you I don't understand.
Then I'll come back cause I just
need time to spend on my family.
Oh. So there's no time
for anything man. Right?
Like so I did them on Sunday nights.
Sunday nights man.
It's like that's the whole night
and I could be with my family.
That was tough cause you would ask me
to do it on Sunday nights. Tough man.
That's what I'm trying to chill. That's
the only time I could do it consistently.
But that cuts into some solid
family. Yeah, for sure. So, but um,
my wife's cool with it. So we've talked
about, I dunno, I'll be back some day.
So just tell you a little break.
Yeah. We still have the studio. Right.
So you can do it there anytime you want.
You know,
you could always do it in the gym too.
You could do different
kinds of fucking times.
Going to say on the go in the gym is
just so many cool fighters that come
through there.
I really can't confirm anything,
but there is something in the works
already with ocean actual production
shit. Some, I know, but this game,
this game, after I walked away,
after I walked away, someone
approached me and said, hey man,
we could do this right. And like a legit
studio, legit production and you're not.
I'm open to it, but nothing's
confirmed. I'm open to it,
but you know how right now, do you
know Eddie if, do you know idiot? Yes.
The Santa bought a bus.
He bought like a school bus and converted
that bitch into a podcast studio.
They drive and he drives it down the
Improv and they plug it into the wall.
Like the Wad podcasts was right on the
go. It's incredible. It's incredible.
I was there the other day and I
was like, oh my God. I'm like,
I want to steal this idea.
I had an idea a long time ago to do it
from one of those trailers that you pull
around where they call it a digital
stream, Gulfstream, Gulfstream. Um,
those are cool looking. Those silver
ones. I've loved those trailer. Cool.
And I was like, this way you could get
one and just pull it around, you know,
or I get Jamie to drive it,
but I don't trust turban
generally looking at more of the but,
but what's the point of having it
on the go? Cause it bring it to um,
like if you say, if I
have a Gig, you're like,
I'm doing the Irvine Improv with Cowen.
You bring the podcast studio,
you park the podcast studio. If it's a
trailer, park it in the back parking lot.
You could actually, like
Eddie, if it has a screen,
you could watch the podcast that's going
on inside his bus, outside the bus.
He's got a flat screen. The back window,
you know, it used to be like a window.
He could see. Yeah. It's not a
window anymore screen. It's a screen.
So from the outside you can actually see
like a full HD version of what's going
on inside. It's really slick, pretty. So
he spent a fuck load of money on it too.
They had like some crazy kickstarted. I
think he spent like 65 grand on that bus.
He's super into crossfit. Right? That's
like his thing. He a comedian crossfit,
right? Yeah. He got hurt though.
Like pretty bad crossfit.
It turns like that gap.
If that switch trouble. How's a, your
backfilling with was pretty good.
It's pretty good. I have a pulled
button muscle right now. That's not fun.
I did something.
I don't know what I did.
I have the fucking
machine got in the back.
You load up with like 400 pounds and
just your cheeks are just fucking boom.
He asked me to get out of there. I was, it
blew my fucking back first. Hyper. Yeah.
Nah, I'm good. I love that machine.
But that's why you asked us all,
I don't think swole shill out Bro.
I asked was,
I had a little bit of a pulled like a
very minor pulled muscle and I fucked it
up worse. Just kept getting worse. Kicking
is putting, uh, putting Justin Myles,
patting them up and beating the fuck
out of him. This is my favorite shit.
Two to three, two, three days a week.
I put a chest protector on. He gave,
wears the tie pads.
I have these giant ass leg pads and
he puts on second leg kick him. Damn.
And we do rounds and I will on that dude.
It's awesome.
If you could hire someone to let
you beat the fuck out of him,
like hold the hold the pads and that
body shots and some rich dude shit.
Tremendous suffering. It's like, come
on Bro, I'll give you $10 around.
Hitting a bag is one thing,
but throwing combinations and finishing
off of the legit full power leg kick
because there's those,
those Goddamn fairtex pads are huge.
You could full power law. I mean I can
like Pedro his, oh, can't full power leg.
He's got a gnarly ass fucking kick.
I would advise Justin, not today.
He takes Beaton's that kid.
But you know what man?
I kid's ball pens entirely
on what kind of pad.
I'll tell you this man.
Anybody who doesn't like
anybody who doesn't know, man,
he's tough as shit. Anybody who doesn't
like, um, uh, holding pads for somebody,
tie pads,
get the Higher Bussa pads higher.
Bussa makes this extra thick
pad with mad fucking foam in it.
I don't know what kind of foam
they're using, but they got it down.
Like the difference between like his
arms would go numb when I would kick them
with the regular one, but with the high
of Boosie, he barely even feels it.
I'm telling you they're different.
The hand. No. Yes, no. I'll just say,
hey,
can
you all hear a brother's 50 diction that
she owed from Brazil where there are
tough and in the students I punched
him in the head. Did you see that? Yes.
John Wayne par showed
it to me is the dumbest.
I've had a fake one. He did
a play one. A pretend one.
He posted the real one, then read created
it. Right. The real one is ridiculous.
These guys are beating the fuck out of
their students. Punching him in the face,
making them stand there and
take head punched. Hard, hard.
But 2015 2015 I mean this guy's teeing
off on the student's face and he loves
it. Why are you laughing? I
blame the students in the,
is that
we're all sober.
It's fucked up. Smoking weed at seven
in the morning. I have my limits.
Thought just what does it think of?
How easy would it be?
The parody that like,
you know what I mean?
Just have the camera angle and like you
could make it look like, have you seen,
got it. You've seen the video.
It's insane. Right? Exactly.
And it's insane how quickly everyone
seen that. You seen it to know, oh,
you haven't seen her. Okay.
It's so the, it's fucked up.
It's so bad. It's not cool.
So off between Facebook and
Twitter and Instagram, Holy Shit.
Everything's just instant
instill that kind of stuff.
The video like that that you could just
like instantly click and some black guys
was trying to get a little bit,
oh my God,
fuck is that high grades punching them.
Somebody needs a beat.
The fucking Sony's a beat the shit out.
That guy's giving those
people brain damage.
I mean the making them stand there and
take brain damage for why I have to be
tough. You fucking idiots. They
do that just once. The new crop.
They want to see how people
react and you know what?
You're going to take a beating.
Right now.
We're going to see how you take
the beating. We're going to study.
Let me tell you one thing. That red car
girl, that man kick him in the legs.
You know like don't fuck it. That's what
they do at tiger. [inaudible] savage.
That guy punches like a bitch by the way,
because anybody who punches really good
should be a knock. Those people like,
oh she's sorry Philip.
Who here would go
to what school?
If you want to time this where it's at.
Four 48 right now for 46 you get,
you get the boot,
the picture Musashi,
saucy and Philip do.
It's got some good fucking hands. Yeah,
he can box good power in his hands.
I fought with it'll kill times.
Does zero,
zero warmup just walked out
there fucking ice cold. Really?
He just be it there with you?
Yeah,
he did like three jumping jacks was like
fuck it. Why do you think he does that?
That seems like, well there's
a, there's some people I was,
I was over there sweat my
ass off doing all the shit.
I looked over at him and he's like,
well, they just cracked his neck.
They took him down side control. Keith
Jardine. So Nice. They don't do much,
man.
That's old school I think.
Okay.
Side control.
What's old school not warming up properly?
I isn't that people say they do that
because the Thais don't warm up when they
fight. I don't know the title first round
really slow because they don't warm up.
No,
because of the bedding.
They don't place the bat
until the fight starts.
So that ties the first round is almost
like they're playing and warming up,
getting the money flowing. Ari
Shaffir was just in Thailand, man.
He just went over to
Thailand for a vacation.
He spent like two weeks in
Thailand just having fun. Oh Man.
Ari's balling out of control
right now. I love it. Easy. He's,
unless he him everywhere. That's
special. This podcast is doing so good.
He's a funny dude, man. He's a funny
dude. He works hard and he's, he's like,
he's doing it the right way.
Like he went to Thailand,
left his computer and his phone
behind five. That's awesome.
And his agent was like, well, what
if we have to reach you? He's like,
you won't can't reach me. You
got to show, I got to show.
I have two specials on comedy central.
You good?
I'll do whatever I want to do
right now is over. You fucked up.
You let the wrong Guy Hashtag blown up.
Hashtag suck it.
I bet he got it.
Even though it was like a I shit talking
fast between Howard stern in him that
got him a lot on my ankle dryness and
Howard stern lost in that 100% what would
our he did was he got
he trolled Howard Stern.
He got how it's turned to
talk shit about how certain,
talked about it for 25 minutes
on a show and then our,
he made a video showing Howard stern how
to Google his name because Howard like
it said a bunch of like false things about
him. You know like about what he did.
Like it's really easy. This is a thing
called Google. I want you to go to,
if your browser would, you probably
have like Netscape navigator company.
Totally mocked him and he did it like in
a really respectful way. The Smart Dude,
very smart.
He's very smart dude
is a beast. You know,
they both had good points.
The fact that Howard didn't know like
talk shit on podcasts because it's good
for us.
But it's also because it's a threat
because he's in Sirius satellite radio and
he's renegotiated his contract,
I'm sure.
And the number one competition for
satellite radio is podcasts. You know,
like if you go through a tunnel,
okay, you go into a parking structure.
I get pissed when I'm listening to fucking
serious and I go to the mall and I go
into the parking structure and the shit
cuts off. It drives me nuts. I'm like,
this is dumb. Okay, this is dumb.
Well plus you gotta pay for it. Yeah.
Well that doesn't bother me cause
I'm rich. But what bothers me,
you are rich and sure that
in their son. No, I hear Ya.
I was going to say it for you
if he did it, but it bothers me.
I like things being for free for sure.
Like everybody does,
but I don't like the technology.
I think it's stupid.
The whole idea that you get a beam it down
from the sky, wasn't it made on earth?
Can't you have an earthly
distribution device?
Arm trouble shooting that
happened? Oh yeah. Costa Phillip.
We'll fight it out of it. No, I
agree. I still think its limits you on
him. I listen to Howard stern all
the time. I love how I'm a big fan.
I listen how listening every day I
listen to Howard stern serious and your
Porsche with the fuck not Ahmed. How
dare you. That's your Porsche out there.
Yes sir. Holy Shit. Hashtag. I was
wondering why it wasn't here. I'm like,
maybe he just left his car here.
Something that's yours.
Hashtag hauling. Wow, look
at you. What year is it?
It's a 2014 holy shit.
Sweet car.
How good is that God damn thing handle?
It's nine nine one. Love it man.
It's like they're on rails. Love
it. You have a Tesla, right? Yup.
I drove a Tesla for a show that Bobby
Ray's ex doing. It's like, it's a,
it's a like a talk show where
you're driving a car. Like the guy,
the guests is driving the car.
So that week was a Tesla.
I love Tesla's holy Shit Dude.
Have you ever driven his car?
He's going for that arm triangle again.
He's really, we're hammering him.
I heard you can download things and Tesla,
we can make it sound like a certain,
like a fry engine. A Porsche engine.
Have you seen that? You know,
I haven't done that.
They should take it away from you.
Have you ever driven a Tesla drive one? It
awesome. Like, no, I've driven in his uh,
driven and Aubrey's the dopest shit.
Like Hentai Tesla, Joe. No, no.
I love them. No noise. Oh, cool.
Making a fake engine noises.
Dom. Super, super dumb. Have 12.
He cannot press. He can press
a button. It, well, he'll,
he'll say into it like arctic monkeys
and then it'll just start pulling arctic
monkeys songs and we'd just be pointed
there. You can name any songs all,
it's pretty dope. Slacker
radio. It's crazy.
The computer screen just Tesla's are
Jack Jack. It's like a giant fucking,
it's crazy. It's pretty, does that thing
go dark when it gets dark out? It does.
Yeah. That's good. The whole screen,
instead of being a white background,
it goes black background.
Yeah.
I'm a big fan of those tax by me and
richest fuck tax break for having small,
right. I mean it's the first
electric car that looks awesome.
People want and that new one.
No,
the Fisker was the first electric
car that looked dope. Those things,
the Fisker and buy one for $50 today.
I will fucking take it. I will take it.
You know what happened with
those Fiskars like blown up.
The bags are like when the,
when the storm hit the east coast,
they were at the docks in North Carolina
and they got flooded and apparently
when they're underwater they just
explode and then that was the end of the
competent. 14 of them blew up on
the docks and everybody's like,
all right, this is why I'm never
going to be under a fucking water.
My to scurry can happen,
man.
If you drive into like a
like water crossing you,
if you're involved in like rain, like do
you ever drive in Houston in the rain?
Well they'll get some, there's some
times where like they get so much water.
Like you're, you know, up to like 16
inches from her car was underwater for,
for chief Fisker.
It'll blow up dude.
You'll be take that flying through the
air like a Popeye cartoon by whatever we
leave.
That's the least of my word was the story
with the guy that the makers of Tesla,
the company didn't they give away
like the patents? Yeah, the pants.
So that other car companies can
you run a mosque is a bad frenzy.
Elon Musk is no joke in Brentwood
and it's genius doesn't cause,
cause if he does that
then there's an industry,
he needs the industry to survive.
So he needs the competition
because once they follow suit,
he's like he's the king forever.
And that's true.
But it's just not scarcity picking.
It's abundant thinking.
People are still gonna buy a test is
even if someone else made guy's a genius,
his kids work out at box and burn in
Brentwood and I see those little rich
bastards. You best believe,
I've talked about the Tesla
home battery. Best believe,
I'm trying to get the new ideas from
their dad is a Tesla home battery so it's
like a generator but it's all electric
goes up through solar and you get like
three days of power on this battery in
your garage and you could stack them.
So you could have nine of these
batteries on your wall. And what,
like what are you saying amounts?
Solar power. Not only that, it's, it's,
it's off the grid.
Solar power.
So like a lot of solar power is
still dependent upon the grid. It's,
which is really fucking stupid.
Meaning you get solar power,
but when the grid goes down,
so does your power,
which seems to me to be dumb as fuck.
So they can set it up differently where
it doesn't go down if the grid goes down,
but it's kind of archaic.
You have a battery room and he solved
all that shit with this wall thing that
he's got and it looks cool.
You get ready.
They're all sold out. But then you can
rely on that for power. I isn't. He's got,
there's gotta be people trying
to shut him down now. There
was, it happened, right? Oh Shit.
Probably go get on that motherfucker
with the test. They just let that shit.
He's too small. It's too
late. Sorry. Sorry about it.
Is that what you were personally? No,
I don't. I don't know about it though.
There's the things like what was his
life like? What does, what does he,
he's just obsessed with work.
He's Batman car injuries. Well,
he's got that. He's got that
space companies. He's just
the building wants to do,
he wants to change the fucking
universe. Oh really? Hm.
Cost of smelling poop.
It's getting Ilan Musk documentary on him.
Not Elon Musk.
There's a bunch of shit on him though.
I mean that those Teslas are awesome.
I want one. Yeah, they're pretty cool.
But you can't drive it to Vegas and if
you leave it sitting out like you are,
you had a problem with that. Right? Like
you took off, went on vacation, came back,
the bitch was like barely
able to get you home. Yeah.
But I think some sneaky fucks might've
been driving it was, I'm not sure.
Yeah cause that was unusual.
But it's stressful.
Like I drove up to Fort Hood
cause he sold, look at this,
look at this Musashi looking for Komora.
I think it's weird that you're allowed
to grab your shorts to the Fed.
You can drive your own shirts but why?
Why not?
But then you can't grab him but you
can't grab somebody else's shade.
But isn't that weird cuts a little
weird that you can grab Carlos.
There's nothing wrong with that.
North south.
I just think short grabbing should
be legal all the way around. Yeah.
Philip was going to make it just to
defend a submission should be legally.
It's weird. What's all
over. What else is there?
If you could have the shorts trying to
take someone down and if any of that
going to have shorts, you shouldn't grab
anybody's clothing. That's ridiculous.
The only reason to hash out the people's
clothes. Like if you have shorts,
you're going to grab this fucking shorts.
What are these wines?
There'd be pants at the side. Yeah.
I don't give a fuck to the side.
What are you gonna do with that?
What I'm understanding
tried to embarrass the guy.
Look at check Congo. Travis Browne. Dude.
Look at big dairy Goodrich. The Pedro.
Yes.
That one over that Garrett Goodridge
reached into the Pedro's fucking pants and
grabbed his dick peanut butter.
He said that he goes,
I made peanut butter out of his nuts.
Some guys to put his feet inside
his book. Yeah, both feet.
There's no rule for that. But he reached
in there and grabbed it, crushed it.
And I'm not kidding.
And somehow or another the Pedro stayed.
He didn't faint. Wow. Casa
filled was getting hammered
in getting, we have no idea.
Look at this. He's holding his one risk
down and punching the shit out of him.
Damn.
These are real net crank that crank this.
Ouch. Nope. We got out of town. He's
working on, he's working on this.
It's totally not getting hit ever.
He's barely getting hit. Someone's out.
Philip who said did you bet? Did you
guys better than plenty? You watch over
the over. What'd you bet on?
I bet on being over around
and a half. Oh, so you won.
Congratulations. Great Bookie, right Ben?
We're not even in Vegas.
My friend in Vegas.
Of course you bet on Frankie your eye.
Maybe you bet it out the soles
to get finished in the third.
I actually bet under cause there is so
far ahead of the game right now when it
comes to bets in the UFC, he's so far
ahead of the game. He's laughing at me.
Might be like at a strong 80
plus percent all time winning.
We had a couple of,
we had a couple of runs we had some
months we would sit down and have lunch
before the fights and I would pick
out some fucking gems and uh, like we,
we went like, shit, we
won't like nine for 11.
You're the best guy to ask a
fucking the couple of ones in a row.
It's like eight out of nine,
nine out of 10 I wish I had,
if we were to hit that nine out of nine
there would have been like, Bro, you,
you know, it's not a bad bet right
now. And I love Conor Mcgregor,
but he's the favorite again. It's all
doing Vegas. Is he a favorite against
raise? Not Mad at that. I'm not mad at
taking all though. I want color to win.
I'm a cotter fan,
but I like money and all those.
Not a bad bet. I see him. Let me,
Eddie, don't tempt me, mother. Fuck.
I just can't believe I'm hearing what
you're saying. But what do you think?
I'm just fucking,
I'll dose so god good.
I can't imagine Conard be a favor when
he's never fought anybody remotely as
good. I got my money on con Gregor minus
one. Oh, all those are favorite dude.
No, it's moving around. Well,
we'll look at it as, yeah,
well I think that it's a, it's closed.
So that's a big spread actually.
Minus one 20 fight.
That was a bucks I got caught or
you've got all that. Oh my goodness.
What is going on, Eddie Bravo.
Crazy thousand dollar gambler.
Once you give him a bankroll racist.
It's like you're riot.
Favorite wins tonight.
Eddie Bravo was going to open
up a school and your honor,
he's going to use officer.
You're going to be paying,
his mortgage is going to be,
he's going to be getting you every month.
Imagine if you just keep chasing
bad money in every month. Oh, Eddie,
what the fuck?
He texted me last night and asked if
it was okay if you bought a check,
you were fucking with me, right? Yeah.
We did bring a stack of cast
stack oak cash staco cash.
Damn. Musashi looks very sad.
You're strike club money.
Yes it is. Can you walk into, you're
single right now, right? No, I'm not.
I got a bad ass fucking leg kick and
forget it. I was going to say though,
I like to have a good time.
No, if you were saying
let's not get it twisted.
Committed. I would,
I was going to ask you if, uh, going
to a strip club was something uh,
you'd like to do. Cause it's just, no,
I hate it. Oh, you hate it. I hate it.
Hate chip clubs. Yeah. He can't stand
them. They make no sense. Why? Why?
I just don't want to see land.
It's fancy.
I just go to God and I pick up where
you walk in and the girl to scaling it.
You know what I'm saying?
And you can look at them because you
don't want them to fucking ask you for a
lap dance. It's a twilight
zone. It was honey dick.
Yet the whole time is what?
Your money.
It's the only club gets
off there to regular club.
No girls are making eye contact
with you. I disagree. Maybe you,
I'm talking about the normal guy like
me when they see a tall fucking UFC
fighter, he fights UFC. Oh my God. Is
that how they do it? What's that face?
What's wrong with their lips?
People have palsy.
They got bell's Palsy in the club.
I don't want that.
Oh look at how beautiful
brand. Normal guys.
Not like you. Okay. I'm saying for me
personally, strip clubs don't make sense.
I go to a bar and meet a nice girl.
We have a fun time.
Well that's a great answer.
Thanks. A good answer. Well,
there's a lot of people that aren't,
are normal guys that feel the same way.
There's a lot of people that just
get upset at the whole process.
I don't want shit stains on my tee shirt,
man.
Them rubbing their ass on me and shit.
Strip clubs need that Fogo de
Chao Red Red Green Button. That's
brilliant.
That's a good to do a combination of
Fogo de Chao Strip club because it's
exhausting to chips.
One of them is pink and something else
and one of them is green and red. Yeah.
So the the pink,
what would it be?
Pink and what would be the
brown red red for that too.
Would you like a Dan? Pink means
bring it over here. Good dance.
But I want to discriminate against my
strong sisters out there that are also
stripping. So I guess shaped
the hustle. I'm not mad at me.
Black girls so can be pink.
Well that's what I said. Pride.
But Brown is probably good too. Yeah.
Brown's not bad like Brown and red.
Maybe me mom who saucy is just uh,
just beaten on the ground man.
Dominating him on the ground.
Every time we look over, he's
on top. How could you say that?
Why you guys aren't even
watching the fight? Nah,
I do watch it enough watching little
of this. He's just dominated him.
Grounded Pouch. You have a big
following in Iran. Did they,
do they have the UFC there? Move
Saucy? Yeah. Um, I don't know.
He's Iranian shore from Holland actually,
but a Iranian heritage.
Ooh, hard elbow. Oh,
another one.
Good girl.
Slice them that slicing elbows.
So nasty. They're novel, right?
Goes across you very good passer.
He gets,
he gets a top half easily.
Yeah.
He's got a strong ground game.
That Henderson fight was sad to see,
man.
I just had to see Henderson get
rock so easy. Yeah. I was like,
this doesn't even seem like the same guy
I can Nursen used to be when to just to
just fight it. He just knocked
out Henderson the first
round. Which saucy did. Oh,
Henderson used to be able to take like
the most insane amount of punishment.
Musashi seem to almost feel
bad about that. Henderson.
I know it's also Henderson's first fight
post TRT because he was on the TRT when
he fought shogun. That was like
the last approved tea. Our tea.
Well now he's fighting Tim boat for
the main event. New Orleans. Yeah.
It was kind of crazy.
Five rounds.
What was supposed to be the main event
and that fight DC. Ryan Bader. Oh,
that's right. Yeah, and then
that became that. That's weird.
It's a weird man event,
but I'm not jumping out of my seat for it.
For a main events,
like if you,
if they set up Weidman versus
Anderson or whatever else,
would they have a backup two oh five or
the train to look like now in a training
camp? No, nothing planned. But if
they know, if, if you know a big time,
two oh five or has a fight like down the
road and he's tray the, call him first.
Well Rockhold said that he was going to
prepare for, for Belford to pull out.
Yeah. I don't think the UFC is
telling them, you know, they mark,
that'd be smart. You put together a
fight and then you designate a backup.
If they start doing like the next guy,
the next guy in line, either you'd have,
I pay him some sort of otherwise,
what's the point? Give them some money.
Cause then if anything happens,
it avoids disaster.
That's tight on a fighter
though. Hey, I had an idea.
Tell me about any ways
you give them a fight.
An easy fight and he's training for that.
He's on the same card.
And then if anything happens,
boom, he just jumps to the
main event. I got an idea.
Tell me if this is valid. I was
trying to, I was thinking last night,
I'm even going to call Dana and
asked him about this. Um, uh,
giving guys opportunities
to have sponsorships, right?
Like everybody's like, well,
Reebok's the only sponsor. Yeah, guys
are going to lose money. What about this?
What about guys release like
almost daily training footage.
Yeah, training footage sponsored
by whatever company it is.
So over a long period of time, like
you're talking about a bunch of videos.
If you're training for a fight,
you got six, eight weeks.
I don't know about you guys, but I fucking
love watching training footage. Allow.
Love it. I get an inspired, I
love watching dudes hit the pads.
I like watching dudes do strength
and conditioning routines.
I like watching dudes get
exhausted. I like watch a p. I just,
I liked watching the training.
Montage has,
I think training videos are like really
good and you don't even need like a
narrator really. I mean,
you may maybe like,
you could have somebody explain what
what's going on or have some text at the
bottom, you know, 7:15 AM, you know,
westside barbell in a matte brown shows
up for work. And then they're like, right,
let's go,
let's go and have a fucking flipped t
have that sponsored by whatever company.
You're all 700 guys. I don't think
you could do it for 700 guys.
But I think you could do it for
a lot of guys and I think you,
well you might be able to do it for
700 guys. Just people wouldn't watch.
People aren't gonna Watch
what they wouldn't count.
They'll happens the capitol,
if they're not watching, then
there's sponsorships. That
worth must much. Anyways,
countdown show, you're catching the guy
like talking to his kid on fucking show.
You know, they show his trainer.
Let's show a little bit of,
if you have 700 guys though, who the fuck
you know who's going to watch Neil bag,
knees training.
I would watch you and I would cause
we're avid fucking well the hardcore fans
are going to watch it for sure.
He gets a sponsor right there.
He's getting sponsors,
right.
He wouldn't get sponsors if it wasn't
for the fact that he's in the UFC.
It got some attention. I do this
already though. I do like a,
when I fought Travis Browne and I fought
Arlovski, I asked the EOC, I said, hey,
I'm on the countdown. They said
no. I said, cool. Got a camera guy.
Got It sponsored by a company who paid me.
Follow me around for four weeks.
I did my own four series videos.
You're very smart with that shit.
You're very smart with marketing man.
You're very smart with the tee shirt
marketing for fighter and the kid.
You got great cool t shirts like I can't
tell you how many shows I show up at a
dude's have fighter in the kid tee shirts.
That's awesome. Super, super common.
Especially the the master Kim.
We just,
I brought you guys takes about domestic
kid takes that dropped this Wednesday.
Gigantic. The mastercam is
gigantic. Yeah. As far as that.
The whole Reebok in the sponge thing.
I can talk about it here.
A little talk about it. Dana
called you a liar and he said, and,
and I know you're not a liar and
I, you know, I love Dana. He's,
he's been my friend for a long fucking
time. And if it wasn't for him,
I wouldn't even be working for the UFC,
the UFC,
if he quit or the UFC got sold to someone
else, I would probably stop doing it.
I really would because I wouldn't
really want to work in any other kind of
environment working for ridiculous dude.
Like Dana is probably the only way I
could ever like be a sports commentator in
the first place.
But I know you're not a liar.
So when he did that interview the other
day and he called you a liar, I was like,
this is a very unfortunate rift
between you two that I hate.
Yeah. Drives me nuts. Well, the the thing
for me, I thought about it all last night.
It's actually been keeping
me up. Um, really it has,
and I talked to my dad about
it whenever I knew this stuff.
I talked to friends and family and May,
maybe I'm the, I'm not lying, but it
does nothing for me to prove this and,
and do all this stuff. Because first
thing, first I'm team UFC, man,
I want to have this platform.
I wouldn't have this fame or I won't be
able to make money that I'm doing now if
it wasn't for Dana White in the UFC.
So I'm anti Yossi in the least bit.
So I'll talk to my dad. And it was, it
was kind of bothering me and my dad goes,
you don't know the,
the grand scheme of everything.
Maybe it helps out other fighters.
Maybe you're the exception where he made
great money and other fighters weren't
and no one me,
he knows damn well I'd co sign on this if,
cause I don't know the overall
plan of this Reebok deal.
So if it helps the majority of fighters,
I'm on board, man. Like I said,
I'm team UFC.
If it legitimizes the UFC with all the
other major sports programs I'm in,
man,
I'm in.
You were just eating a facto about your
sponsorships and that's where it got
weird because he said you were lying
about your sponsors, but, but then,
but I talked to Dan, so I don't know
when that interview was. I talked to Dan.
He called me,
went over the sponsors and those sponsors
that he read on the show that that's
from a, that's from a banner.
Those aren't sponsors.
Those are gyms that I train it.
Those aren't even sponsors.
And one sponsor that he said,
I just think he was misinformed.
Someone misinform them. I've never
heard that. That's not my sponsor.
That's naming sponsor. I work.
When you have all the lists,
you mean you gave it to me.
You gave me a list of all your sponsors
and what you actually got paid. Yeah,
I can have it. I have proof. I have
tax returns. It's not about that.
It's not a bad thing you sent me.
Was that a tax return?
If that's the initial breakdown.
Yeah. Yeah. Well that's, that's it.
That settles the argument is
released that cause I don't want it.
It's not about that. I don't want to
get into this pissing contest with Dana.
I late you think two lanes? I
disagree. You're in a pissing contest.
He pissed Tanya. Well, in
some on that Landsberg show,
he basically pulled his dick out. Peed
all over here. I agree. But my so,
so what am I going to go to go to war
with Dan over this? Like I said, no,
you don't have to do anything.
I'm not the, I don't,
I don't wanna be the Tito Ortiz of this
Reebok. Do you know what I'm saying?
I fucking love the UFC man.
I love working for the UFC.
There's a bigger picture here.
Beat. I might be the exception.
I feel like fucking Adam Sandler and
Billy Madison when he's in class and he's
all core fill more like bore fell and
thinks it's funny and no one says shit.
Well I was the guy who went boar fill
and every other UFC fighters. Shit. Uh,
we like this deal and I was like, Oh shit.
All right, well that's not true though.
A lot of people don't like this deal.
So this is,
this is a deal that a lot of people
criticized that that's fine and you can't
criticize,
but listen to this,
you'll see is no different than than a
Microsoft or an apple. There's gonna.
You gotta crack some
eggs to make an Omelet,
so there's going to be some guy's upset.
But in the grand scheme of things,
it might be better for the overall
concept of all the UFC fighters. I Dunno.
Maybe I'm the exception,
you know what I'm saying?
But it doesn't do me any good to release
all this stuff and say, Dana's wrong.
That's not what I'm about.
I'm about being part of something bigger
than just myself, if that makes sense.
Okay. Yeah. I mean, look, it's
up to totally up to you. I mean,
you do what you gotta do. I don't have
to do any, if somebody might me liar,
I would release the papers.
If I knew that I had everything on paper,
they would show that it wasn't a liar.
Like it doesn't make sense.
Call you a liar.
It makes sense.
I ask you what you were getting paid
and then well can you send me that?
That's like a rational conversation but
gets irrational when someone calls you a
liar when you know you're not a liar
and you do have the tax returns.
That seems to me like the rational
response to that is to just show and then
maybe you guys could have like,
okay I was wrong. You know? Okay.
I didn't know that people were making
that much money cause I don't know if he
actually knew how much money guys
like you who are very clever with your
marketing and really good at promoting
yourself, how much they were making.
I mean he didn't obviously didn't talk
to you about it, how quickly talk to me,
but did you mean about the banner?
She said he was, he was talking about,
and Dana doesn't owe me any fest thing.
Dana though it doesn't have to do shit.
Right. He's the captain of
the ship. I'm just, you know,
I'm just watching this thing, man.
I'm just a guy that works on the ship.
So for Dana being the captain,
he doesn't owe me anything.
But if anyone just told me, said,
listen, Brendan, it's not about you.
It's better for the UFC. Cool. Oh Man.
I'm in a fortunate position where, listen
man, I don't ever have to fight again.
I've won. I've won the game. I'm not here
to fight this fight. I've won the game,
man. I don't ever have to fight again.
Do I want to? Yeah, I do. Do I have to?
Nah, man. I don't have to do shit of a
successful podcasts of a sisal merchandise
business.
I surround myself with very successful
people are way smarter money like Joe
Rogan, Brian Callen. You know what I'm
saying? Brian counts not smarter than you.
I'll tell you right now,
dude. He definitely, you
know what I'm saying? So, so,
so for me, I do not, I'm not
getting this pissing contest right.
If it's good for the UFC, it's
good for Brendan Shot. Okay, cool.
Well that's not the answer I wanted
to here. Damn. I know people,
people wanted me to throw
grenades. Man. That's not my fight.
I know it's not my fight. You know
how it goes, rather than I work.
I was the one who wanted to get
you guys together and just like,
I love both of you.
I wanted to get you guys together and
just stop all this fucking Dick wave and
bullshit. I would love that, man. I'd
love to just sit down with them now.
Maybe we could do it. Yeah. Meanwhile,
we got the fucking main event coming
up here and take the time on this three
hour. How are we really, I just got
to reset everything so we don't, well,
let's reset it now. We'll
be right back, folks.
We're going to reset
this for the main event.